US SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
IN FISCAL REVIEW WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN
RESPONSE THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS. AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVER GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO OUR PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEES
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WILL BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
FOR THOSE SENATORS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY CAN YOU
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELVES NOW.
THURMOND IT'S NOT LIKE. GREAT
GO AHEAD IDENTIFIED CENTER MAN
REPRESENTING SENATE DISTRICT
THIRTY SEVEN GREAT. AND IF YOU
HAVE ANY SUPPORT STAFF WITH
YOU. I DO NOT WRITE ANY OTHER
SENATORS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
OKAY WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES IN HOUSING
AGENCY ON THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. FOR
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SO
PLEASE ALL OF YOU WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY MEET
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL HELP ELIMINATE ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK WHEN YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED USE THE RAISE YOUR
HAND FUTURE IN THE PROGRAM. AND
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK THE POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO IN MUTE SELECT ON YOU BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. THEN WHEN
YOU ARE FINISHED ARE I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MEAT- AND WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN YOU CAN ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO HEARINGS.
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCE REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND
WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE ALSO-
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THROUGH THE
TELECONFERENCE ARVEST THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND WILL
DISPLAY IT ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW THAT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 THE
ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT SEVEN SIX
EIGHT NINE. FOUR ONE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID THE
FEEDBACK YOU MUST BE TO STICK
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY. SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE- I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. AND WHILE
WE'VE MADE EVERY EFFORT TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESSING
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IS CLOSE TO
THE SAME MANNERS CUSTOMARY.
THERE'S ALWAYS SOME POSSIBLE
LACK TIMES. AS WE ADJUSTED THE
USE OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES AND
TOOLS. WE WILL NOW BEGIN
HEARING AND MR HACKER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THEY'RE JUST
SUGGESTING SOUNDS. COMMITTEE
STAFFER CAN CALL THE ROLL.
SIX
SORRY WE'RE JUST HAVING A
LITTLE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY WE
NEED TO CALL THE ROLL IN ORDER
TO ESTABLISH QUORUM. YOU MMHM.
THE SHOW SKINNER YES HERE
NIELSEN. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CORTESE DOLLY. THE RAZA. EGGMAN
WHERE'D- MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ IN.
THE S. B. I MEAN THIS FOR HIS
FAMILY. NEWMAN BOB HERTZBERG.
PAN STERN BY KELSEY. WELCOME.
SERVICE STATUS FOR FREE- ALL
RIGHT SO. FIVE BEFORE WE BEGIN
THE PRESENTATION AS WE
INDICATED IT WILL BE PRESENTED
BY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THIS
ONE TO- MAKE A FEW KEY POINTS
THAT PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC WE
ARE CALIFORNIA HAD ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS WHO ALREADY WERE
FACING THE FACT THAT 50% OF
THEIR INCOME WAS GOING TO RENT
AND ACCORDING TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST DURING THE
PANDEMIC. 53% OF THE JOB LOSSES
THAT HAVE OCCURRED HAVE BEEN IN
LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS SO AS I
POINTED OUT THESE ARE ALREADY
HOUSEHOLDS WHO ARE CONFRONTING
A POTENTIAL DIFFICULTIES
MEETING RENT- D. BILL THAT WE
PASSED LAST YEAR AB THREE ZERO
EIGHT EIGHT WHICH INCLUDED
EVICTION PROTECTIONS THEY SET
TO EXPIRE AT THE END OF THE
MONTH. AND AS WE KNOW RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE IN CALIFORNIA STILL
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION WORKERS
WHO REMAIN UNEMPLOYED.
ADDITIONALLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN PASSING CARES ACT
TO PROVIDED TWO POINT SIX
BILLION IN FEDERAL RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AVAILABLE- BOTH TO
THE STATE TO DISTRIBUTE AND
SOME DIRECTLY TO OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- AND THESE THE-
ISSUES THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
HEARING TODAY. WOULD GIVE US
THE ABILITY TO. MAXIMIZE THE
USE OF THOSE FEDERAL DOLLARS
AND ADDITIONALLY ADDRESS THE
FACT THAT OUR CURRENT BILL WITH
THE FICTION MORATORIUM IS SET
TO EXPIRE AT THE END OF THE
MONTH. AND MISTER RIGHT SURE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS BEFORE THE BILL
PRESENTATION. YES SURE MADAM
CHAIR I. HAVE NOT TOO MUCH
OBJECTION EXCEPT I GUESS
PROCESS WE DIDN'T GET THIS
LANGUAGE UNTIL YESTERDAY THAT
TO ME THERE'S MAJOR POLICY HERE
AS WELL AS FISCAL IMPLICATIONS
THAT DISPOSE OF THE ASSEMBLY
ABSTAIN ON THIS- WE'LL SEE WHAT
THE FINAL BILL. CONTAINS THANK
YOU CENTER NIELSEN. ALL RIGHT
SO LET'S BEGIN WITH THE
PRESENTATION OF. AB SEVENTY
NINE WHICH IS BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YOU MAY PERCENT. I'M ASSUMING
THAT YOU ARE THE PRESENTING
ENTITY MY CORRECT YES CORRECT
CARE BULLETS WE THEY SHOULD I
THINK YOU SHOULD BE IN OUR-
REMOTE SCREEN. HI THERE YOUR
THREE. RIGHT I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR SKINNER AYE STERN NIELSEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DIRECTLY WITH THE EPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- TODAY I WILL BE
PRESENTING ON SB SEVENTY NINE
AND- A BUDGET BILL JUNIOR WHICH
AMENDS THE CURRENT BUDGET AND
SB NINETY ONE A TRAILER BILL
WHICH EXTENDS THE STATE'S
EVICTION MORATORIUM AND CREATE
THE STATE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM TO ALLOCATE FEDERAL
RENTAL AND LANDLORD REALLY FUN-
THE STARTING. WITH SB EIGHTY
NINE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR- SB
EIGHTY NINE AS TO TECHNICAL
ITEMS TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT TO PROVIDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT OR ABCD.
UNNECESSARY IF ORTIZ AND
FLEXIBILITIES TO IMPLEMENT AND
ADMINISTER THE FEDERAL FUNDS
ALLOCATED TO CALIFORNIA UNDER
THE RECENT FEDERAL COULD ONLY
FILL. CONSISTENT WITH THE
FEDERAL LEGISLATION THESE
TECHNICAL BUDGET ITEMS
AUTHORIZED HDD TO TRANSFER AND
USE UP 210% OF THE FUNDS
PROVIDED. ADMINISTER THE
PROGRAM. AND MOVING ON TO THE
TRAILER BILL SB NINETY ONE
INCLUDES PROVISIONS THAT EXTEND
THE STATE'S EVICTION MORATORIUM
AND ESTABLISH THE STATE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. AND CHARITY
NOTED- CORRECT RELEVANT
BACKGROUND THAT PANDEMIC HAS
RESULTED IN LOSSES OF INCOME
NEGATIVELY IMPACTING
CALIFORNIANS. RENTERS AND
HOMEOWNERS- WELL DIRECT FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE. AND EXPANDED
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND HELP
THEM INDIVIDUAL PAY RENTS MANY
TENANTS ARE BEHIND ON THEIR
PAYMENTS. OCCURRING LARGE
AMOUNTS OF RENTAL ARREARS AND
MANY LANDLORDS HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED AS TENANTS
ARREARS OUT UP. LATE AUGUST IN
RESPONSE THIS. PASSED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED EIGHTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT WHICH INCLUDED THE
NATION'S STRONGEST STATEWIDE
EVICTION PROTECTION- AB THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT HAS PREVENTED MANY
CALIFORNIANS FROM EXPERIENCING
ADDICTION BUT THE PRIMARY
PROVISIONS OF THE FLY EXPIRE.
ON JANUARY THIRTY FIRST- HE
SAID GOING ON- AND I'M SPEND AT
APOLOGIES FOR THAT THE BILL
MEMBERS ANYWHERE NOW THESE ARE
EIGHTY SEVENTY NINE AND EIGHTY
EIGHTY- THE BILL EXTENDS THE
STATE'S CURRENT EVICTION
MORATORIUM FOR TENANTS WHO ARE
UNABLE TO PAY RENT YOU TO COPE
AND RELATED FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
FIVE FIVE NINE SO FROM JANUARY
THE END OF THIS MONTH UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH. OF THIS YEAR.
SENATE CONTINUE TO PAY 25% OF
THEIR RENTAL OBLIGATIONS AS
REQUIRED UNDER AB THIRTY EIGHT.
THROUGH JUNE- TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DURING THIS TIME IF TENANTS
CONTINUE TO PAY AT LEAST THE
AMOUNT THEY'RE PROTECTED FROM
ADDICTION FOR ANY UNPAID RENTS
THAT HAS ACCUMULATED. DURING
THIS COVERAGE PERIOD. THE BILL
ALSO- EXTENDS EIGHTY THIRTY
EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR HOMEOWNERS
RELATED TO MORTGAGE
FORBEARANCE. IT ALSO EXTENDS
THE PROHIBITION ON COMMENCING
AN ACTION IS SMALL THINGS
COURTS RECOVERED- BUT NINETEEN
RENTAL THAT- TO AUGUST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THE GOING
INTO THE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM- IN THE BILL
ESTABLISHES THIS PROGRAM TO
ALLOCATE THE RELIEF FINDS THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS RECEIVED
DIRECTLY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- DESIGNATED FOR
RENTAL ASSISTANCE. CALIFORNIA
WILL RECEIVE AN ESTIMATED TWO
POINT SIX BILLION OF WHICH ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION WILL COME
STRAIGHT TO THE STATES. AND ONE
POINT ONE BILLION IS ALLOCATED
DIRECTLY BY THE US TREASURY TO
COUNTIES AND CITIES WITH
POPULATIONS OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND- THE PROGRAM
STRUCTURED THE PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE ELIGIBLE LANDLORDS WITH
IMMEDIATE RELIEF THROUGH THE
PAYMENT OF 80% OF THEIR
TENANTS. RENTAL ARREARS
ACCUMULATED FROM APRIL APRIL OF
LAST YEAR THROUGH MARCH OF THIS
YEAR. IN RETURN LANDLORDS
RECEIVE THAT THE MEDIA
FINANCIAL RELIEF AGREED
ACCEPTED AS PAYMENT IN FULL SO
FOR GIVING THE ROOM REMAINING
RENTAL THAT. OF THEIR TENANTS
DURING THIS GIVEN TIME. HCD
WILL ADMINISTER THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FUNDS
RECEIVED BY THE STATE THROUGH
EITHER A BLOCK GRANT ALLOCATION
TO LOOK LOOK HOLIDAYS OR
THROUGH A THIRD PARTY
IMPLEMENTOR. LARGER COUNTIES
AND CITIES MAY RECEIVE A DIRECT
BLOCK GRANT- ALLOCATION FROM
THE STATE TO SUPPLEMENTTHEIR
DIRECT ALLOCATIONS FROM THE U.
S. TREASURY- WHILE FUNDING FOR
SMALLER COUNTIES WILL BE
ADMINISTERED THROUGH A THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR- OR
IMPLEMENTOR. COUNTIES OR CITIES
THAT PREFER NOT TO ADMINISTER A
LOCAL PROGRAM CAN REQUEST THAT
THEIR STATE AND FEDERAL
ALLOCATION FUNDS BE
ADMINISTERED THROUGH. THE STATE
PROGRAM. FOR CONSISTENT
TREATMENT THOUGH LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS- THROUGHOUT THE STATE
COUNTIES OR CITIES THAT
SUPPLEMENT THEIR ALLOCATIONS
WITH THE STATE BLOCK GRANTS-
THEY WILL FOLLOW THE SAME STATE
RENTAL PROGRAM PROVISIONS THAT
WERE DESCRIBED ABOVE. AND
THAT'S TO CREATE CONSISTENCY
ACROSS THE STATE. NOW REGARDING
ALLOCATION STATE FUNDING WILL
BE ALLOCATED FOR JURISDICTIONS
BASED ON OUR PROPORTIONATE
SHARE OF POPULATION- HOWEVER
THERE IS A SMALL COUNTY KERR
ABOUT SO THE SMALLER COUNTIES
THAT HAVE POPULATIONS OF TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR LESS. WILL
RECEIVE A PORTION OF THAT
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION LARGE
JURISDICTIONS WITH POPULATIONS
ABOVE TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND WILL
RECEIVE FUNDS BASED ON A
PERCENT OF TOTAL POPULATION.
BOTH LANDLORDS AND TENANTS MAY
APPLY FOR THE PROGRAM- FOR
ASSISTANCE THE FEDERAL PROGRAM
DOES EMPHASIZE LANDLORD
PARTICIPATION IN CASES WHERE
LANDLORDS CHOOSE NOT TO
PARTICIPATE THEY STILL CANNOT
GET BACK TO YOU MAKES TENANTS
FOR NON PAYMENT OF RENT. OF
RENT SO LONG AS THEIR TENANT IS
PAYING 25% OF RENT- JUST
THROUGH THE END OF THIS
COVERED. THROUGH THROUGH THE
END OF JUNE. IN THESE CASES AN
ELIGIBLE TENANT MAY APPLY TO
THE PROGRAM ON BEHALF OF THEIR
LANDLORD. AND THEY MAY APPLY
FOR UP 225% OF THEIR ARREARS-
BUT THEY'VE BEEN MUST USE THOSE
THAT 25% TO PAVE POPULAR
MONTHLY RENTS- IN REGARDS TO
TIMING RECOGNIZING BOTH THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY AS WELL
AS A STRICT. FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR DEPLOYING THE
FUNDS. HCD WILL ALLOCATE THE
BLOCK GRANT FUNDS IMMEDIATELY
AFTER JURISDICTIONS OPT INTO
THE PROGRAM. AND CONTRACTS ARE
EXECUTED GRANTEES MUST THEN
OBLIGATELY 65% OF THEIR STATE
FUNDING. BY JUNE OF THIS YEAR-
WITH ALL OF THE FUNDS BEING
EXPENDED BY AUGUST AND THE
REASON FOR THESE DATES IS
REALLY TO ADHERE TO FEDERAL
FUNDING REQUIREMENTS. WHICH
MAKE FUNDS AVAILABLE THROUGH
THE END OF THIS CALENDAR YEAR.
HOWEVER ANY GRANTEE THAT DOES
NOT USE OR DOES NOT OBLIGATE AT
LEAST 65% OF THEIR FUNDS. BY
THE END OF SEPTEMBER ARE AT
RISK OF LOSING THEM. BASICALLY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN TAKE
IT BACK- AND SO WORTH NOTING IN
CALIFORNIA IS ABLE TO OBLIGATE.
AT LEAST 65% OF THE DIRECT
APPLICATION THAT WE RECEIVE.
THEN WE WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL ALLOCATED-
REALLOCATED FUNDS- TO ENSURE
PROGRAM INTEGRITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PROGRAM FUNDS
PROVIDED TO GRANTEES WILL BE
SUBJECT TO THE SAME RECORDING
AND VERIFICATION REQUIREMENTS.
AS THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN
SPECIFIED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND IN ADDITION HDD
MAY REQUEST ADDITIONAL
REPORTING TO ENSURE PROGRAM
FUNDS ARE BEING USED-
APPROPRIATELY- AND IMPORTANT TO
KNOW H. CD WILL ALSO BE
REPORTING MONTHLY TO THAT-
JOINT. LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR THE DURATION OF
THE PROGRAM- IN REGARDS TO
PERFORMANCE METRICS- FOR THE
STATEWIDE PROGRAM AND THE AND
THE BLOCK GRANTED FUNDS. SO
INCLUDING THE INTENT OF THE
PROGRAM IS TO REALLY MAXIMIZE
THE IMPACT OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS
WILL BE RECEIVING. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND TO SET UP A- A
DESIGN PROGRAM- THANK IT CAN
GET THE MONEY OUT EFFICIENTLY
EQUITABLY AND WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY IN REGARDS TO
THE REPORTING- SO INCLUDING
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO SAY- THANK
YOU AND THAT SENIOR STAFF FROM
THE- BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES
AND HOUSING AGENCY. OR HEARING
DATE- THERE ON- PARTICIPATING
ON THE LINE. AND THEY- HAVE
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN DEVELOPING
THIS PROGRAM SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER. QUESTIONS. WITHIN THE
TIME COMES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I WONDER
IF WE SHOULD PRESENT ON THE
SECOND. BILL SINCE THEY ARE-
INTER INTEGRAL TO EACH OTHER IF
AND THEN START OUR DISCUSSION
PORTION. LOOKS GOOD OKAY SO
LET'S HEAR THE PRESENTATION ON
AB AT AND THEN WE WILL- SEE IF
THERE'S QUESTIONS FROM THE
FLOOR AND FROM COMMITTEE-
APOLOGIES- THERE MAY BE ONE
ISSUE. FOR A DO THAT. VOTE
FIFTIES MAY I JUST WASN'T- I
DIDN'T TRACK THAT YOU WERE THAT
YOU HAD SAID EIGHTY EIGHT YOU
DID BOTH SEVENTY NINE EIGHTY
ALL RIGHT SO WE'VE GOT- BOTH
AMONG BEFORE US ONE BEING THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR AND ONE
BEING THE TRAILER BILL SO WE
NOW CAN SEE WHAT. THE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS THERE ARE I HAVE A
FEW BUT LET ME SEE WHAT'S FROM
THE- FLOOR BEFORE BEGIN MINE-
SENATOR DORADO THE SENATE OR
WHITE HOUSE SKI. OKAY LET ME
GET- SENATOR NEWMAN SO LET'S
START WITH SENATOR DRAWS SO AND
THEN I WILL START A LIST WITH
THE OTHERS. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- OKAY FIRST
QUESTION IS ABOUT THE- WHEN
THEY CALLED THE THIRD PARTY
THAT'S GOING TO BE INVOLVED IN-
A CARRYING THIS OUT- THERE'S
SOME INFORMATION OBVIOUSLY THAT
WILL BE AVAILABLE TO US. IF YOU
COULD DESCRIBE WHAT KIND OF
INFORMATION WILL BE AVAILABLE
SO FRANKLY SO THAT WE COULD
LEARN FROM THE PROCESS AND-
KNOLL WHAT IS WORKING AND
WHAT'S NOT WORKING AND TRACKING
THAT INFORMATION COULD YOU
DESCRIBE WHAT THEY WOULD
INFORMATION THEY WOULD GATHER.
YES SENATOR RAZA I'M GONNA HAVE
THAT QUESTION OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE- AT THE AGENCY THANK
YOU. SENATOR HI THIS IS LINDA
ON COKE LIEBHARD AND THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF HOUSING AND
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY AND I'M VERY
HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
AND SO THE- THE THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR PRIMARILY WILL BE
COLLECTING ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT'S REQUIRED TO VERIFY
ELIGIBILITY. WITHIN THE
APPLICATION SUBMITTED EITHER
FOR LANDLORDS OR TENANTS I'M SO
THE FEDERAL PROGRAM OUTLINES A
NUMBER OF REQUIREMENTS AND TO
BE ABLE TO DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY AND THEN ALSO BE
ABLE TO FACILITATE. THE
RECORDING ON THE USE OF THE
APPLICATIONS. SO WHAT KIND OF
INFORMATION WOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO US I DON'T I DON'T MEAN
PRIVATE- INFORMATION BUT WHAT
KIND OF INFORMATION WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO US AS-
LEGISLATORS. THAT WE COULD USE
TO. UNDERSTAND THE SUCCESS OR
THE FLAWS OR WHATEVER IT. IS
YOU KNOW WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO
US TO KNOW. YES OF THE
INFORMATIONAL BE CORRECT
COLLECTED INCLUDES- BASIC
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION SO AND
WHERE THE WHERE THE HOUSEHOLD
IS LOCATED AND THEN-
INFORMATION THE BILL WILL
PROVIDE I. D. THAT'S REQUIRED
OR THAT THEY WILL- INCLUDED AS
AN OPTIONAL HE'S BEEN FORMATION
ABOUT- THEIR HOUSEHOLD. AND IN
THIS AND ALSO INCLUDE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE SUCCESS
OF THE APPLICATIONS SO WE WILL
INCLUDE INFORMATION ABOUT WHO
FINANCED THEIR SUCCESS RATE ON
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WERE. I DO
WITH THE GRANT AND THEN VALUE
OF THE GRANTS THE TERMS OF THE
GRANT. AND DO YOU- THEIR WAY OF
KNOWING THAT WE COULD GET THAT
ARE GETTING THAT INFORMATION
NOT UNTIL. WENT WITH THE DATES-
UNTIL LATER IN THE SUMMER BUT
CAN WE GET IT IN SORT OF IN
REAL TIME AS CLOSE TO REAL TIME
IF POSSIBLE. YES SENATOR I
BELIEVE IN THE IN THE BILL
LANGUAGE THERE'S A MONTHLY
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS WE'RE
THROUGH OUR OUR ENTITIES
THROUGH BCS AGING EACH CITY
WILL BE PROVIDING A MONTHLY
REPORT. OKAY FOR THE MONEY
THAT'S GOING STRAIGHT TO THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. THE DO THE
STATE RULES APPLY TO THEM AS
WELL OR IS IT ONLY THE FUNDING
THAT WE THAT COMES TO US FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THEY
WILL GO OUT- TO THE
JURISDICTIONS. AND OVER THE
SAME REQUIREMENTS THE SAME
RULES. FORTY FOUR CAN THE LOCAL
AREAS ARE THEY GOING TO BE ABLE
TO COME UP WITH THEIR OWN RULES
ON DISTRIBUTING THE FOR THE
ASSISTANCE THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE THAT THEY GET
STRAIGHT FROM THE- FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. YES SENATORS IT
FOR- PRIMARILY ALL FUNDS THAT
ARE COMING THROUGH STILL WILL
BE REQUIRED TO COMPORT WITH THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS. AND THEN-
FOR JURISDICTIONS THAT ELECT
TO. TO MINISTER THOSE FUNDS AND
THEY WILL BE REQUIRED TO WORK
WITH THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS.
TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR A STATION OF
QUESTION OF THE STATE FUNDING
THEN THEY WILL NEED TO LOOK FOR
ALSO WHAT THE STATE PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS. OKAY THANK YOU-
WHAT ARE THE BARRIERS TO- ALLOW
THE SAME PERCENTAGE OF A OF A
RENTAL RELIEF TO THE BACKGROUND
WHAT OTHER BARRIERS TO ALLOW
THAT SAME PERCENTAGE WHETHER OR
NOT A LANDLORD PARTICIPATES. I
CAN ONLY TAKE A SMALL. YEAH THE
PRIMARY- STRUCTURE THERE IS
REALLY CONVENTION INCENTIVIZE
PARTICIPATION WITH THE
LANDLORDS AND THE BILL LANGUAGE
INCLUDES HIGHER VALUES THE
LANDLORD LEVEL BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE ABLE TO HAVE A REQUIRE
IF YOU'RE ABLE TO HAVE THE
GRANT BUT THE LANDLORDS AND WE
CAN HAVE THE- THE DECISIONAL
ARREARS WAIVED AND- REDUCE THE
DEBT BURDEN THAT HOUSEHOLDS
CARING. IF THE LANDLORD IS NOT
WILLING TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT
PROGRAM AND THE MONEY GOES
DIRECTLY TO THE TENANT AND
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO REMOVE THE
ADDITIONAL- DEBTS THAT THE
HOUSEHOLD WAS TEARING THEM SO
THE RATIOS ARE DESIGNED THAT
WAY TO INCENT LANDMARK
PARTICIPATION SO THAT WE CAN.
GET THROUGH THIS PROCESS AND
HAVE REDUCED THE AMOUNT OF DEBT
THAT HOUSEHOLDS ARE CARRYING
OKAY THANK YOU AND THEN- WHAT
THE WHAT DO YOU THINK IS
AVAILABLE WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
RENTERS AS FAR AS PROTECTING
THEM FROM RACIAL OR ETHNIC
DISCRIMINATION LET'S SAY
LANDLORDS USES THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. REACH AN
AGREEMENT WITH JUST CERTAIN
KINDS OF TENANTS AND NOT OTHER
KINDS OF TENANTS WHAT WHAT
OPTIONS ARE PROTECTIONS. TO
THOSE FOR OUR TENANTS HAVE. YOU
MIGHT COULD YOU TAKE A FINANCE
MARKET TAKE THAT OR OKAY SURE
TERM HAPPY TO TAKE THAT. I AM
SENATOR ONE OF THE- ONE OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE- THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. SETS THE
SENSUALLY THE SAME STANDARDS
THAT WE HAVE FOR- AT HOUSING
SOURCES OF FUNDING SO FOR
INSTANCE WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
A- NEW REGULATIONS AROUND
SECTION EIGHT VOUCHERS WHERE.
YOU CANNOT DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
THE SOURCE OF THE FUNDING- THIS
LANGUAGE INCLUDES THE SAME
LANGUAGE THAT THAT THE LANDMARK
COULD NOT DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
THE SOURCES USING THOSE THAT.
THAT THAT THESE FUNDS TO BE
ABLE TO PAY THE. RENT ON BEHALF
OF THE TIME. OKAY DRAWS AS THE
I DO WANT TO ALSO ADD. IN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE DO HAVE
TWO POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT. OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING TO DEAL
WITH SUCH THINGS SUCH AS THIS
SO- ONE OF WITHOUT. OKAY GREAT
YEAH I JUST WANNA SAY AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT'S
GONE INTO IT- I SPECIALLY OF
SUPPORT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
EXTEND THE MORATORIUM ON ON THE
VACATIONS- OBVIOUSLY. IT'S NOT
PERFECT THERE'S SO MANY ISSUES
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED BUT
WHEN WE'RE FACING THE TSUNAMI
IT IT IT REALLY OF EVICTIONS
IT'S REALLY URGENT TO- A
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND MOVE
FORWARD WITH ACTUALLY WITH BOTH
OF THEM. OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE OF
THE HOLES IN THE PROBLEMS I
WOULD HOPE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
WORK REAL HARD FOR THE NEXT
SEVERAL MONTHS TO ADDRESS THOSE
AND USE AS MUCH OF THE
EXPERIENCE AND THE- INFORMATION
IS POSSIBLE TO DO IT- NOT. WAIT
AFTER TILL AFTER JUNE THIRTIETH
BUT ACTUALLY BEFORE THAT- TO
GET THE INFORMATION SO- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH VENTURE. THANK
YOU SENATOR DRAWS SO I HAVE ON
THE LIST NOW SENATOR Y. CASKEY
SENATOR NEWMAN SENATOR CORTESE
SENATOR MELENDEZ. THEN WE SEE
IF THERE WAS SOMEONE ELSE OKAY
CENTER MCGUIRE. ALRIGHT LET'S
PERCENT INTERMITTENT CENTER
MINIMALLY. APOLOGIES OF
SENTIMENT BUT IN GENERAL. ALL
THESE. CENTER IS RAISING CATTLE
WITHIN YOUR HAND UP FEATURE ON
THE- SO YOU STAND A FUTURE OKAY
OF THE WILL- CODE CENTER
WORKOUTS SKI RIGHT NOW. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FINANCE SO THE
LANDLORDS PARTICIPATION IS
LIMITED 280% OF THE RENTS THE
REAR OF THE CUMULATED FROM
APRIL TO MARCH FIRST SO LET'S
SAY. THE FIRST LANDLORDS
BECAUSE I CAN'T IMAGINE ANY
LANDLORD NOT TAKING THIS DEAL
BUT LET'S SAY THE LANDLORD
TAKES TO DEAL AND THEY GET THE
CHECK 480% OF. WHATEVER
BALANCES SO THE DEBTOR THE
ATTENDANT HAS PAID THE 25% TO.
AS STATED IN STATE LAW FOR NOW
APRIL FIRST COMES AROUND. AND
THE- TO TEN IT PAYS 25% OF
THEIR- RENT. AND UNDER THE OF
MY UNDERSTANDING LAW THEY CAN'T
BE AFFECTED. WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THE LANDLORD FOR APRIL MAY AND
JUNE UNTIL THIS BY THIS
MORATORIUMS ON WHAT HAPPENS
WITH THAT OTHER 75% DO I HAVE
MY COLLEAGUE RESPONSE FROM THE
AGENCY THANK YOU. SURE THIS IS.
YEAH AT THE TIME IN. AND IT.
THIS AMY WILSON- FROM THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES A
HOUSING AGENCY GOOD AFTERNOON-
YES AS YOU CORRECTLY POINT OUT-
OF THE- WAY THAT IT'S MORE TIME
EXTENSIONS WRITTEN THAT I'M
MOVING FORWARD- RENTERS NEED
TO- A THE 25% TO. AT YEAH I
TOLD THEIR- PUBLICATION UNTIL
LANDLORDS AND PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM EVICTION- AND
AS YOU ALSO STATE- ANY BALANCE
WILL ACCRUE- AS DEAD AS IT HAS
PREVIOUSLY- OUR HOPE IS THAT.
THE FUNDS WILL CONTINUE TO FLOW
THROUGH THIS PROGRAM AND- AS WE
ARE ADVOCATES- D. CURRENT
RENTAL ARREARS THAT. EXISTS
RIGHT NOW FOR THE PRIOR PERIOD
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO TURN OUR
ATTENTION MOVING FORWARD. I
GUESS MY FOLLOW UP QUESTION ARE
THERE LIMITATIONS WITH THE
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WE WOULD
RECEIVE THAT WOULD NOT ALLOW
THAT- FOLLOW UP A REAR EACH
PAYMENT. OR WITH THAT. REQUIRE
THIS BODY ON ITS OWN TO PUT IN
OUR SEPARATE STATE FUNDS IN
ORDER TO TAKE CARE THAT JUST
THAT LITTLE. THREE MONTH
PROBLEM- THERE ARE- THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM- DOES- WETRULY
EMPHASIZE THE EXISTING RENTAL
ARREARS- OVER PERSPECTIVE-
PAYMENTS FOR RENT AND SO-
THAT'S- BECOME THE FOCUS OF OUR
PROGRAM PROGRAM AS WELL- SO THE
PERSPECTIVE PAYMENTS- ARE
LIMITED TO ARM CERTAIN IN
INCREMENTS OF TIME- BUT- AS YOU
STATED RIGHT NOW THE FUNDING
IS- IS REALLY. AREN'T LOOKING
BACKWARDS AND NOT MOVING
FORWARDS AND OUR HOPE IS THAT
THEY WILL BE- ADDITIONAL FUNDS
FLOWING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT WILL. MAKE THE
FORWARD GOING PAYMENTS
AVAILABLE THERE ARE NO- THERE
ARE NO BARRIERS IN- THIS
CURRENT BILL I RELATED TO A
PROSPECTIVE PAYMENTS- EXCEPT
FOR THE THOSE ESTABLISHED BY
THE FEDERAL. CIRCUIT MANAGER IF
I IF I MAY I. HEARD DURING THE
NEGOTIATIONS SAID PRECEDED THIS
THE SUNDAY DEAL THAT THERE WAS
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WAS AVAILABLE FOR LEGAL AID
ASSISTANCE THING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO THE LANDLORD HAS TO
HAVE AN AGREEMENT THAT THEY
FORGIVE AND THERE MAY BE PEOPLE
THAT FORGET THAT THEY- FORGIVE
THAT TWENTY PERCENT. IS THAT
STILL THE ADMINISTRATION'S
FINANCE INTENTION THAT THERE'S
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO
GO INTO. HELP OUT LEGAL AID IN
THE OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE GONNA NEED HELP. FIVE
HUNDRED THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THERE IT STILL REMAINS
THIRTY ONE MILLION IN THE
CURRENT YEAR BUDGET FOR LEGAL
ASSISTANCE THROUGH THE-
NATIONAL MORTGAGE- FILAMENT ONE
RIGHT NOW I'M JUST CURIOUS
BECAUSE WE MADE THAT DECISION
IN JUNE WILL WE THOUGHT THE
PROBLEM WAS ONLY SO BIG. AND
THE PROBLEM GOT MUCH BIGGER IN
THIS IS RATHER COMPLICATED AND
I'M WONDERING IF IT WHY THERE
IS AN ADDITIONAL MONEY FOR
LEGAL AID TO DEAL WITH. THIS
COMPLICATED. SITUATION AND THEN
ALSO COME JULY FIRST WHEN
PEOPLE MAY BE ACTUALLY NOT
PROTECTED BY THIS BILL IF WE
DON'T TO ANOTHER BILL. WHAT'S
THE FINANCES THINKING ON THAT.
CHAR AND THERE WAS AN
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED
MILLION THAT WENT TO COLLEGE OF
FAITH THAT MAY ALSO BE USED
TOWARDS LEGAL ASSISTANCE- SO
THERE IS ADDITIONAL DOLLARS IT-
ON TOP OF THE THIRTY ONE
MILLION- AND THAT IS IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET AS WELL. AND IS
THAT MONEY GOING OUT THE DOOR
FOR LEGAL AID OUR COMMUNITY
THAT. IS GOING TO BE. AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES SAID
DEALING WITH THE TSUNAMI. COMES
UP. IS THAT MONEY ARE ABOUT THE
TIMING ON THAT I WOULD HAVE TO
GET BACK TO YOU I BELIEVE- THAT
THAT PROGRAM HAS MORE RECENTLY
BEEN- STOOD UP FOR US. BEGUN IN
SO I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE THE
NUMBER OF FUNDS- BUT YES IT IS
IT'S- IT'S AND IT'S AN EXISTING
PROGRAM. YEAH I AM WELL WERE
MADAM CHARGES. IN THE TEN YEARS
I'VE BEEN HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE I'VE BEEN FIGHTING
WITH FINANCE TO MAKE SURE THAT
MORE MONEY GOES TO LEGAL AID.
AND I HAVEN'T GIVEN UP THE
FIGHT I'M JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU SEND THE CHECK
OUT TO THE COMMUNITY THAT NEEDS
REPRESENTATION WITH THAT.
HIGHER YIELD. THANK YOU SENATOR
WHITE- YES THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO KNOW SO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WOULD BE HELPFUL TO
HAVE. INFORMATION THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE THAT- THAT MONEY HAS
BEEN DISTRIBUTED THE MONEY THAT
WAS ALREADY APPROPRIATED. TO
LEGAL AID. UPDATE US ON WHETHER
IT'S BEEN. DISTRIBUTED RIGHT
LET'S HEAR FROM SENATOR NEWMAN
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR CORTESE
SENATOR MELENDEZ THEN SENATOR
MEN AND SENATOR MCGUIRE GO
AHEAD ALL RIGHT WITH THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- SO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE BILL
PROVIDES UP 280% IS IT UP 280%
OR IS IT EIGHTY PERCENT. YEAH
I'D- FOR. RENDERERS HI AT 80%
SO IT'S A FIX 30% BUT THAT'S
THAT'S GONNA BE APPORTIONED
AGAINST A FINITE AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL FUNDS CORRECT. YEAH
THAT IS BASED ON THAT- ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION- ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION THAT THE STATE IS
CURRENTLY GETTING. CHAU DO WE
HAVE SOME ASSURANCE. THAT THE
FUNDS WILL BE SUFFICIENT TO
ADDRESS THE REAR EDGE ACROSS
THE STATE. AND WHAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN BETTER TRANSACTION- B. THE-
I BELIEVE FINANCE WOULD SAY
THAT THE ARREARS- THERE'S NO
WAY AT THIS POINT TO REALLY
DETERMINE WHAT THOSE ARREARS
ARE- POTENTIALLY THEY COULD BE
AT A CELLULAR STATED BEFORE
HUNDRED MILLION- MAYBE EVEN
NEED WE THINK THAT'S IN THE
LOWER END COULD BE HIGHER- AND
SO THIS IS A FINITE AMOUNT OF
MONEY IT WILL GO BASED ON THE
ROUNDS HAS DEVELOPED THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM- AND AGAIN WE WILL
WE ARE CONTINUING CONTINUALLY
AS- MY COLLEAGUE FROM AGENCY
SIDE. I'M LOOKING FOR-
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD ANY
IF IT'S IF IT'S A FIXED PAYMENT
OF 80% AND THAT IS A CLEAR AS A
VERY OF ITS IT IT'LL BASICALLY
FIRST COME FIRST SERVE WILL
WILL WILL TO DISPATCH DISPERSES
MONEY UNTIL SUCH TIME. AS WE'VE
EXHAUSTED THE FUNDS- WELL THAT
IT IS A AT FINITE AMOUNT OF A
DOLLAR TO PER ITSELF THE SET UP
TO. GO OUT AND BROWN'S SO THE
FIRST ROUND WOULD REALLY BE-
HITTING THE NEEDIEST-
HOUSEHOLDS SO THOSE UNDER 50%
AREA MEDIAN INCOME- AND THE
SECOND ROUND WOULD EXPAND THAT.
A BIT AND THE THIRD ROUND AS
WELL BUT JUST WANTING TO KNOW-THAT THE IDEA IS TO BE
EQUITABLE IN TERMS OF
DISTRIBUTION. BUT ALSO TO HIT
WHERE THE NEED IS MOST. AND
THAT IS WHAT WILL GO OUT IN
ROUND ONE OF THIS PROGRAM I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM AGENCY HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD TO THAT. I'M
SURE I CAN TRAIN IN- THIS AMY
WILSON AGAIN- FROM AGENCY. A
GOOD AFTERNOON US SENATOR- I
WANTED TO JUST ADD OR
EMPHASIZE- THAT- THE PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED TO- START FIRST WITH
ELIGIBILITY- AND- THEN- MOVE
FORWARD IN AT DIFFERENT LAYERS
OF PRIORITIZATION AS ERICA
DESCRIBED. WITH THE ROUNDS-
AND- WE ARE TRYING TO AVOID A
SITUATION OF FIRST COME FIRST
SERVE BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT- NOT ALWAYS YOU KNOW THAT
SOMETIMES IT TAKES SOME TIME TO
REACH DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES-
AND- THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
MAY BE NECESSARY TO REACH THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AND YOU KNOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT- THOSE IN NEED
ARE APPLYING- AND SO THE-
THEREFORE THE IDEA OF HAVING
THESE- KIND OF. BACKGROUNDS OF
PEOPLE CAN APPLY AT ANY TIME IN
THE AND BE ORGANIZED INTO
ROUNDS BASED ON WHERE THEY FALL
INTO THE ELIGIBILITY CATEGORY.
I HOPE THAT'S HELPFUL THAT IS
VERY HELPFUL SO THAT THAN WITH
RESPECT TO ELIGIBILITY AT MY
UNDERSTAND GUYS THAT THE
THRESHOLD IS 80% OF AMI'S TO
CORRECT FOR IT AT THE AT THE
HIGHEST. YES SIR- BUT THAT THE
FOCUS IS THE FEDERAL LAW- AT
EMPHASIZES A PRIOR TO USING.
50% AND UNDER BUT BUT YOU CAN
GO UP AS HIGH AS EIGHTY IS MY
GUESS. SO IS TO THEN THERE
THERE'S THEIR SERVICE SEPARATE
FROM WHICH- THERE ARE SOME
LARGE NUMBER OF. TENANTS WHO
HAVE NOT PAID RENT WHO WHO
SUGGESTED MEDIAN INCOME IS
HIGHER THAN 80% DOES THIS
LEGISLATION MAKE ANY PROVISIONS-
OR IS THERE ANY ALLOCATION FOR
LANDLORDS WHO MIGHT. IHAVE NOT
RECEIVED A REQUEST FROM TENANTS
WHO ARE ABOVE THAT THRESHOLD.
WELL I SHOULDN'T. QUALIFY THAT
THERE ARE. A NUMBER OF WAYS TO-
DEMONSTRATE. ELIGIBILITY AND SO
IN ADDITION TO THAT 80% FIFTY
PERCENT- THERE IS- AN UNNAMED.
BEING UNEMPLOYED FOR A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF MONTHS- IN THIS
RECENT CALENDAR YEAR- AND SO
THAT IS ONE OTHER WAY BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE FEDERALIZED.
IS IT A FAKE ABOUT THAT 80% AND
OUR STUDENTS RECEIVE THIS
LEGISLATION THAT IT DID DOESN'T
ADDRESS THAT. SPECIFIC PROBLEM-
YOU KNOW JUST FOR TENANTS. WHO
ARE IN ARREARS BUT WHO DON'T
MEET THE 80% OR LOWER A MY
THRESHOLD. UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO
THE STRUCTURES OF THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM THAT IS CORRECT.
RICHARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU US SENATOR AND
SENATOR CORTESE. THANK YOU
RICHARD- KIND OF PICKING UP ON
THE ON THE QUESTIONS THAT- THE
CALL FROM FOURTEEN TO ASSESS
REGARDING THE KNOWN LEVEL THE
NEED I THINK THE RESPONSE WAS
THERE'S NO WAY THAT WE COULD NO-
AND I'LL STIPULATE FOR PURPOSES
OF. THE QUESTION COMMON WANT TO
MAKE THAT THERE'S NO WAY WE CAN
NO IN EXACT TERMS RIGHT DOWN TO
THE PENNY. BUT I HAVING SPENT A
NUMBER OF YEARS. IN A ROW
HOUSING BUSINESS AS A PRIVATE
SECTOR INDIVIDUAL BEFORE
INVOLVED. IN FULL TIME ELECTIVE
OFFICE AT THE AGE OF FORTY FIVE
YEARS OLD SOME YEARS AGO- I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A
LANDLORD IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT AS WE SIT HERE
TODAY WHO DOES NOT KNOW- THE
NUMBER OF TENANTS WHO ARE
DELINQUENT. ON HIS HIS OR HER
pIT WITH THEIR INCOME WAS. AT
THE POINT THEY WERE APPROVED
FOR RESIDENCY AND THAT- IN THAT
HOUSEHOLD. IN THAT TENDENCY. SO
WHAT I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
IS WHY. WE ARE REQUIRING IN THE
LEGISLATION A PRE APPLICATION
PROCESS THAT IT WOULD OCCUR UP
AND DOWN THE STATE. QUICKLY
OBVIOUSLY- THAT WOULD GIVE US
AN INVENTORY OR PRE ASSESSMENT.
OF THE ANTICIPATED APPLE CAN
AMOUNT FROM EACH ONE LANDLORDS
IS INTERESTED IN THE PROGRAM- I
PERSONALLY BROUGHT THIS UP- YOU
KNOW THROUGH CHANNELS HERE. I
WANT GIVEN THE SPECIFICS OF
THAT- POKING OVER THE PAST FEW
DAYS SINCE THE PROPOSAL- YOU
KNOW HAS HAS ENTERED INTO THE
REALM OF PUBLIC DISCUSSION- BUT
CAN YOU CAN YOU. PLEASE RESPOND
AS TO WHY THAT COULDN'T HAPPEN
OR WHY WE ARE GOING TO RECORD
TO THE SOURCE. THE SAME FOLKS
WHO. WHO NEED TO APPLY TO GET
THE MONEY IN THE FIRST PLACE TO
HAVE THAT INFORMATION WHY WE'RE
NOT ASKING THEM THAT AHEAD OF
TIME SO WE KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
THESE DISPARATE NUMBERS. WHICH
SEEM TO RANGE FROM. ANYWHERE
FROM THREE AND A HALF TO FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN NEED YOU
KNOW DOWN TO FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION. WHICH IS CORRECT.
SENATOR LYNN LINDA CLEAVER DRUM
UP FROM PCS STAGE AND- I THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION. WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING UNDER THE PROMISE
THAT WE WILL NEED TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH FUNDING INTO
THE HANDS OF LANDLORDS. AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND SO THE
PROGRAM THAT WE DESIGNED REALLY
EMPHASIZES SPEED UP DELIVERY-
BUT ALSO WITHIN THE DESIGN OF
THE PROGRAM THE- THE WAY THAT
WE'RE SETTING UP THE
APPLICATION IS ESSENTIALLY A
PRE APPLICATION PROCESS. I'M SO
THE LANDLORD OR TENANT CAN
INITIATE THE APPLICATION. THEY
PROVIDE ALL THE INFORMATION TO
DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY AND ALSO
TO SHOW WHAT THEIR NEED IS. AND
THEN FROM THAT THEN WILL HAVE
TO BEGINNING OF THE DATABASE OF
WILL SHOW US THAT INFORMATION
FROM WHICH WE CAN DRAW DOWN
APPLICANTS THAT- CAN BE
SUPPORTED THROUGH AND THROUGH
EACH ROUND. I'M SO WHILE IT'S
NOT SPELLED OUT AS A PRE
APPLICATION REQUIREMENTS WE
BELIEVE THAT BY THE WAY THAT
THE INFORMATIONAL COME INTO THE
SYSTEM IT WILL HELP US BE ABLE
TO SIZE AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT- THE NEED AND BE ABLE TO
THEN- BRITT RESPONDED WITH A-
THREE POINT FIVE TO. RESPOND TO
THE DEMAND IN TERMS OF HOW
WE'RE DOING OUTREACH
COMMUNICATIONS AND WHERE WERE.
INSURANCE PROCESSING
APPLICATIONS. IN IN THEIR QUEUE.
IS WHAT I'M IN PARK. ABOUT A
PART OF OUR- I'LL SPEAK FOR
MYSELF BUT I BELIEVE PART OF MY
RESPONSIBILITY AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO COMMUNICATE
ACCURATELY TO THE PUBLIC AS TO
HOW THEIR EXPECTATIONS SHOULD
BE CALIBRATED WHEN WE START
ROLLING OUT ASSISTANCE AND I'M
NOT CLEAR AS YOU DESCRIBE. THIS
DE FACTO PREOPTIC AREA
APPLICATION PROCESS YOU JUST
DESCRIBED. HELLO HOW WE GET THE
PROPER NARRATIVE OUT BEFORE
ROLL OUT OF THE DOLLARS BUT TO
THE PUBLIC AT LARGE AS TO WHAT
THEIR EXPECTATION SHOULD BE IN
TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S
ENOUGH MONEY HERE BUT WHETHER
OR NOT THEY'RE GONNA BE SOME
PEOPLE WAITING. OR IN LINE FOR
A LATER ROUND UP. I DON'T KNOW
HOW WE- GET THAT INFORMATION
IT'S SIMILAR. TO SENATOR
ROSEN'S QUESTION EARLIER- HOW
DO WE GET REAL TIME INFORMATION
THROUGH THIS PROCESS- CORD CORE
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
GET THAT INFORMATION. HOW DOES
ANYBODY GET THE INFORMATION.
ONCE YOU HAVE IT SO THAT WE CAN
COMMUNICATE BEFORE. BEFORE THE
ROLLOUT OF THIS FUNNY STARTS TO
HAVE A- AN IDEA ABOUT THE- YES
YES SENATOR WE NEED TO- ONE OF
THE ELEMENTS OF THIS PROGRAM
THAT WE THINK IS CRITICAL IS
THAT COMMUNICATIONS AND PUBLIC
OUTREACH COMPONENT I'M SO PART
OF THE LEGISLATION INCLUDES
EIGHTY EIGHT CONTRACTS TO BE
ABLE TO BUILD ON THE EXISTING
HOUSING IS KEY- OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN THAT THAT WE DEVELOPED
AS PART OF THE RESPONSE TO AB
THREE OH EIGHT EIGHT. I'M SO AT
THE AT THE SIGNING OF THIS
DISABILITY WOULD IMMEDIATELY
MOVE FORWARD ON COMMUNICATING
INFORMATION ABOUT- THE NEW
REGULATORY CHANGES AS WELL AS
BEGINNING TO STAND UP THE
STRUCTURE FOR THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND WE SENT
APPLE TIME OVER THE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS CREATING AND WHAT WE'RE
CALLING THE GEOGRAPHIES OF NEED
NOW. WHICH IS CREATED BY THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
AND IS AVAILABLE ONLINE AND
THAT ESSENTIALLY PULL SENSIBLE
INFORMATION ACROSS THE STATE
LEADERS SAID WITH I'M CONFIDENT
PACKED COMMUNITY DEMOGRAPHICS
AND B. AND IT GIVES US AND
ESSENTIALLY AND- A PLACE TO
BEGIN TO FOCUS OUR OUR REGION
COMMUNICATIONS- MESSAGING YEAH.
AND ONE THING THAT'S BEEN
REALLY WE'VE WE'VE BEEN WE'VE
BEEN LISTENING TO A NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE RUN
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS BOTH
WITHIN OUR STATE SOME OF THE
OTHER STATES AND CLARITY OF
MESSAGE- COMMUNICATION
COMMUNICATING THE ELIGIBLE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA AS A
FRIEND- ARE TWO THINGS THAT
REALLY- HER ACROSS ACROSS THE
WHOLE COUNTRY AND THAT THAT OUR
STATE IS VERY IMPORTANT- ONCE
THAT IT SETS EXPECTATIONS- IN
TERMS OF WEIGHT WHO'S ELIGIBLE
HIS NOT. AND SHOES SO THAT
APPLE CAN SEND THEY DO REQUIRE
GOING TO BE MORE SUCCESSFUL IN
GETTING THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
SO WE WILL ENSURE THAT OUR
COMMUNICATIONS AND UTREACH
CAMPAIGN BOTH- LEARNS FROM
LESSONS OVER THE LAST YEAR AND
THEN REALLY BUILDS ON ON THOSE
ON THOSE PRACTICES. AND THE
OTHER THING TOO IS THAT WILL
REALLY EMPLOYER PARTNER THAT
WILL PLAY A PARTNERSHIP BASED
STRUCTURE WHERE WE WILL WORK
WILL USE THIS INFORMATION AND
THEN PUSH IT OUT THROUGH TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS NONPROFITS
AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS. THAT
ARE DOING VERY WELL IN THAT IT
INTO IT COMMUNITIES THAT ARE TO
HAVE THE- THAT THE HIGH. NEED
AND TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SAN. GETS SYNCED THE
HANDS OF THOSE NEED IT NOW. AND
THE COMMUNICATIONS WILL ALSO BE
ABLE LINGUAL- WILL BE
ACCESSIBLE AND WILL BE- AT
CREATED IN A WAY THAT THAT
HELPS. YOU KNOW MEETS MEETS
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS WHERE
THEY ARE. AND TO BE ABLE TO GET
THEM THROUGH THIS PROCESS. AND
IN TERMS OF THE INFORMATION
FLOWING BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND- WE WILL BE COLLECTING AND
AGGREGATING INFORMATION ON A
MONTHLY BASIS. AND PROVIDING
THAT AS AS A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE SO THAT. YOU CAN BE
ABLE TO SEE. WHERE THE
APPLICATIONS ARE COMING AND I'M
WHO THEY'RE SERVING AND STUFF
THE FOLLOWING THE. CADENCE OF
THE FINANCES THERE IS ARE GOING
OUT. BUT I GUESS WHAT I'M-
TRYING UNDERSTAND. IS THE ROLE
OF THIS COMMUNICATION ENTITY.
AS PART OF ITS ROLE BESIDES
LETTING INDIVIDUALS KNOW IF
THEY'RE QUALIFIED OR NOT
LOADING COMMUNITY BASED
AGENCIES KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING
ON THE GROUND IS PART OF THE
ROLE. THAT AFTER IMMEDIATELY
AFTER THIS FROM SO CALLED PRE
APPLICATION PROCESS THAT THEY
WILL ANNOUNCE. TO THE RESIDENTS
OF THE CITY CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND-
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS. HOW
MUCH MONEY WE ACTUALLY HAVE
RELATIVE. TO THE PRE
APPLICATION THE- IT JUST SAYS
YES OR NO WILL THAT BE
ANNOUNCED THE MINUTE WE HAVE
THAT INFORMATION. BEFORE MONIES
DISTRICT. I THINK THE THAT'S I
HEAR YOU ON THE YES AND NO
SENATOR- BUT I THINK IT'LL BE A
LITTLE BIT HARDER TO GET TO
THOSE THAT THAT STATIC POINT IN
TIME BECAUSE I. BELIEVE THAT
THE APPLICATIONS WILL COME IN
ON A ROLLING BASIS- AS
INDIVIDUALS WILL HEAR ABOUT THE
PROGRAM AND ARE ABLE TO SUBMIT
APPLICATIONS INTO THE SYSTEM-
SO WE'LL BE DOING ESSENTIALLY
POINT IN TIME REPORTING- AS THE
PROCESS ROLLS OUT. I'M VERSUS
HAVING KIND OF A COMPREHENSIVE
REPORT OUT FRONT- THAT WE WITH
AND WORK AGAINST FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE PROGRAM. YEAH
JUST A- LITTLE BIT OF THE- BUT-
I THOUGHT YOU SAID THERE'S A
PRE APPLICATION PROCESS WHEN I
ASKED WHETHER OR NOT. LANDLORDS
WOULD BE REQUIRED. TO INDICATE
WHAT THEY'RE ANTICIPATING NEED
WAS JUST PRIOR TO THE
REPLICATION I THOUGHT I HEARD
YOU SAY YES WE HAVE BUILT IN.
IT SOUNDED LIKE ON A DE FACTO
BASIS. BUT NOW I HEAR YOU
SAYING THAT THEY WON'T HAVE
THAT WE WON'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION- COLLECTIVELY. WE
WILL WE WILL HAVE THAT ARE ONLY
BASIS AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
WORRIED ABOUT EIGHT. I DON'T
WANT TO BE AT ALL. OFFENSIVE IN
ALL RIGHT TO JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO- BEEN AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
WHERE WE- CERTAINLY HAD SOME
ISSUES THERE IN TERMS OF.
GETTING INFORMATION OUT ON A
TIMELY BASIS OF NOTHING'S
PERFECT ESPECIALLY IN A NEW.
SITUATION LIKE THIS. BY IT DOES
SEEM LIKE TIME AND AGAIN. WE
HAVE TRIED TO GET DELIVERY OF
DOLLARS OUT DELIVERY OF
VACCINES- DELIVERY OF ANY
NUMBER OF THINGS OUT WITHOUT
REALLY KNOWING THE METRICS OF
WHAT THE NEED. IS ANXIOUS SIX
SUGGESTING THAT THERE IS A
POINT IN TIME. APPROACH THAT
CAN BE DONE VERY VERY QUICKLY.
I WOULD PRESUME IN A WEEK'S
TIME. A BY ANY LANDLORD WHO
SIMPLY PRESSES A BUTTON ON A ON
A- ON A COUNTY PROGRAM. PULLS
UP THE RENT ROLL IT DELIVERS
THAT INFORMATION IF THEY WANT
TO BE ELIGIBLE. OF FOR THE FOR
THE ROLL OUT OF DOLLARS SETS
ITS OWN SUGGESTING I'M NOT I'M
PRODUCING HEARING IS THAT
THAT'S NOT PART OF THE PLAN. IN
A TROUBLED BY THE END OF
CONCERNED BY THAT. IN IT I
THINK IT'S- LIKELY TO CAUSE A
LOT OF COMMUNICATION PROBLEMS
IN A LOT OF BROKEN
EXPECTATIONS. WERE DEFEATED
EXPECTATIONS BY PEOPLE- CAN I
THERE HOW OR THE IMPLEMENTERS.
THE PROGRAM IMPLEMENTERS
ACTUALLY. SHOWS AND I HEARD
THAT THEY HAVE TO BE QUALIFIED.
IN ALL THAT IS IT. THIS IS OURS
ARE THE CHOSEN. BY COUNTY OR
THE OR THE CHOSEN BY AN RFQ
PROCESS IN OUR OF P. PROCESS OR
THE THIS H. CD ALREADY HAVE A
BENCH. OF IMPLEMENTERS READY TO
GO IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
I'M HAVING SOME UNDER. I JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE DETAIL OF
HOW THAT'S GOING TO WORK IN AND
pANSWER AND JUST LOOKING FOR
SOME OF THOSE BASIC. TOPLINE
ADMINISTRATIVE RALPH'S THAT
WOULD OCCUR HERE- THE ROUTING.
SENATOR AND I'LL CANNOT
QUESTION ACK TO MY COLLEAGUE
LYNN WHO HAS SOME MORE DETAIL
ABOUT HOW- THE PAYMENT WILL
TAKE PLACE. THANK YOU. YES
SENATORS SO WE HAVE BEEN-
WORKING THROUGH EXTENSIVE
MARKET RESEARCH- WITH A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT SERVICE. PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTERS SHE REALLY I
UNDERSTAND AND IDENTIFY WHAT
SYSTEMS AND TECHNOLOGIES AND
SERVICE PROVISIONS ARE IN THE
MARKET SPACE. AND AND SO FROM
THERE WE WILL WE WILL SELECT
EIGHT EIGHT PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTERS THROUGH- HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT- AND THEN
AWARD BACKS. DOWN THERE. IN
ORDER MULTIPLE IMPLEMENTERS IN
THE STATE OR ONE PRIMARY WHO IS
SERVING OUT. A TWO OTHERS. AS
WE ENVISION AND IT'S THE LATTER.
THE THANK YOU OF LESLIE I HAVE.
THAT'S THE QUESTION HE SAID THE
PREVIOUS BUDGET HEARING WHICH I
HAVEN'T REALLY RECEIVED AN
ANSWER ON WAS HOPING TO RECEIVE
IT OFFLINE- AND I WAS HOPING IT
WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED THE REST
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS BY BY NOW
BUT IT WAS JUST A QUESTION AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT THE FEDERAL
FUNDS- ARE RESTRICTED. HOW TO
RESET THE TO. BUT CASH TENET
ASSISTANCE I'M ASSUMING NOT
SINCE WE'RE GOING TO BE PAYING
MONEY FOR- MARKETING OKAY
PARDON THE TURN WE'RE GONNA BE
PAYING MONEY FOR HI I
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THIS MAY BE
COMING FROM OTHER SOURCES. BUT
OVERHEAD FOR HIM IMPLEMENTERS
AND SO FORTH IT IS ARE THERE.
HOW MUCH LATITUDE DO WE HAVE AN
IS THERE ENOUGH LATITUDE. TO
DIRECTLY OUT OF THESE FUNDS
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE NOT ONLY
LEGAL ASSISTANCE BUT TENANT
MEDIATION PROGRAM STOOD UP-
THAT CAN BRING IN- BUT
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS CENTER
AND A CONTENTIOUS SITUATION AND
HELP RESOLVE THEIR ISSUES. ARE
AND SENATOR CORTESE APOLOGIES
THAT YOU HAD NOT RECEIVED A
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTIONS FROM
THE PREVIOUS HEARING- I CAN
CIRCLE BACK ON THAT BUT IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS TODAY- B. TWO POINT
SIX BILLION AND SPECIFICALLY
THE ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
THAT'S COMING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO THE STATE UP 210%
MAY BE USED FOR- ADMINISTRATION
WHICH MAY INCLUDE THEIR SORT OF
THE COMMUNICATION ASPECTS OF IT
AS WELL AS THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THE ACTUAL PROGRAM ITSELF.
SO THAT IS NOT THE SOURCE OF
THOSE FUNDS- THE- DIRECT THE
OTHER DOLLARS ARE ARE MEANT TO
BE DIRECT. PROGRAM USES SO FOR.
XANDER UTILITY- WITH A- FROM
THE GOVERNMENT AND IN OUR STATE
PROGRAM UNDER CONTROL- SO
THAT'S SORT OF THE USE OF THOSE
DOLLARS- IN REGARDS TO- YOUR
QUESTION LEGAL AID. AGAIN THERE
WAS- EARLIER QUESTION- IN
REGARDS TO THAT AND THERE IS
THERE IS THERE IS AN AMOUNT
CURRENTLY THIRTY MILLION- THAT
GOES THROUGH THE COURTS. FOR
LEGAL AID THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL- AMOUNTS OF ABOUT
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS AND IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT HAS
BEEN PROPOSED THAT WOULD ALSO
GO THROUGH THE COURTS AND I
SPECIFICALLY FOR- THAT THE
THIRTY. AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT
RELATED- CLAIM ON A SYSTEM
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY LEGAL
AID BUT THE- THIRTY MILLION
PLUS THREE HUNDRED- THROUGH
COLLEGE AND THEY MAY BE USED
TOWARDS- THE MEDIATION AND
LEGAL AID. THANK YOU AND I DID
HEAR THE RESPONSE THE LEGAL AID
AND- I. AND I KNOW MY COLLEAGUE
GO FROM ALAMEDA BROUGHT THAT UP
IT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND I
THINK HE MIGHT EVEN AGREE THAT
A MEDIATION ATTEND A HARDSHIP.
RESOLUTION PROGRAM- MAY BE
SEPARATE FROM FROM JUST LEGAL
ASSISTANCE TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST- AN UNLAWFUL DETAINER
THEY SHOULDN'T BE OCCURRING
THERE. OF COURSE TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS LAST QUESTION. WILL
THERE BE A CALL CENTER SET UP-
BY THE MASTER IMPLEMENTOR OR BY
THE PUBLIC RELATIONS ENTITY.
FOUR BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OR BY SOMEBODY OTHER THAN-
CONSTITUENT SERVICES IN OUR
OFFICES BUT TO RESPOND TO- THE
ANTICIPATED- Q. AND A CONCERNS
QUESTIONS ETCETERA THAT ARE
COMING DIRECTLY FROM THE
CONSTITUENTS THE TENANTS HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ARE
ASKING THAT QUESTION TWO OF MY
COLLEAGUE LYNN THANK YOU. YES
SENATOR THAT THAT IS DEFINITELY
PART OF THE STRUCTURE OF THIS
PROGRAM- SO. THE WAY THAT WE
ENVISION IT IS THE PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTER WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR STANDING UP A
CALL CENTER THAT IS A
MULTILINGUAL AND AVAILABLE
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK- WE DON'T
ALSO HAVE ROBUST EMAIL- TEXTING
AND- AND WEB SERVICES AS WELL-
WITH THE PHONE SERVICE WE THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT PARTS OF PARTICULARLY
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE DIRECT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ISSUE. I'M
LEARNING TENANTS AS THEY'RE
GOING TO THE PROCESS AND HOW
QUESTIONS- AS A FILLING OUT
THEIR APPLICATION. I'M SORRY IF
YOU YOU MENTIONED THAT BEFORE
HEARD YOU TALK ABOUT THE MULTI
LINGUAL NATURE OF THE OF THE
SERVICE OF THIS GOING UP I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND IT AS A CALL
CENTER SO THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THAT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU- SENATOR
CORTESE- SENATOR MELINDA. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST A FEW
BASIC ENQUIRIES- UP TO THIS
POINT. WHAT IS THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
RECEIVED FOR THIS PROGRAM. I'M
CAN I TURN THAT OVER TO AGENCY.
FOR SENATOR I'D HAVE TO LOOK
PRECISELY AT THE NOTES BUT IT
WAS THE APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
ALLOCATED- BUT WE CAN GET BACK
TO YOU WITH THAT THE PRECISE
NUMBER. OKAY SO ROUGHLY ONE
POINT TWO BILLION TO DATE AND I
ASSUME ALL OF THAT MONEY WAS
ALLOCATED AND USED. CENTER I'M
SO SORRY HAVE TO CORRECT MYSELF
THAT'S THE AT THE OTHER
LOCATION IS THE ONE POINT FOUR
FIVE BILLION. OKAY THE ONE
POINT FOUR FIVE BILLION WAS
ALLOCATED IN THAT ALL OF THAT
MONEY WAS ALLOCATED TO NEWS IS
THAT CORRECT. I'M SO SORRY
ALLOCATED AND- HONORING US WITH
HER TENURE ALL THAT MONEY WAS
GIVEN OUT CORRECT. I'M NO NO
SENATOR THAT THAT IS JST
REACHED US THE STATE THE STATE
AND IT WOULD REQUIRE ON THE
STAND UP OF THIS PROGRAM SHOULD
BE. WHAT THE ACTUAL NEED IS.
HOW MANY PEOPLE OR THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT THAT. SENATOR I WOULD
AGAIN I WOULD GO BACK TO MY
EARLIER COMMENT THAT THERE
ISN'T DIRECT EVIDENCE
SUGGESTING- HOW MUCH THE
ARREARS ARE- YOU KNOW WE LOOK
AT SURVEY DATA TO BASICALLY
TELL US WHAT THE MEDIA'S AND
BACK INTO. ABOUT A THIRD OF
CALIFORNIA RANCHER ADULTS WERE
BEHIND ON RENT OR IN CERTAIN
ABOUT PAYING THAT RENT- AND
MORE THAN TEN PER OF RENT
HEALTH WERE WORRIED BEING
EVICTED- OVER THE NEXT TWO
MONTHS SO SAY USING THAT AS A
PROXY A 10% OF HOUSEHOLDS
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLD RENTERS IS
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS- IF YOU USE THE
AVERAGE MEDIAN RENTS FOR THE
STATE WHICH IS ABOUT FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS- IF YOU AGAIN
USE THAT AS SORT OF A PROXY FOR
THE NEED OF. IF THOSE RENTERS
ARE A MONTH BEHIND YOU'RE
LOOKING AT ABOUT NINE HUNDRED
MILLION IN ARREARS IF TWO
MONTHS BEHIND THAT COULD BE ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION. SO AGAIN
THERE'S NO- THAT THAT'S BASED
ON SIR DATA AND LOOKING AT THE
WHO KNOWS HOW. WHO HAVE SAID
THAT THERE CERTAIN IN REGARD TO
PAYING RENT. AND THERE'S NO.
DATA THAT THAT THERE BUT WE
USED AS- AS A PROXY FOR THE
NEED. THE POTENTIALLY IT COULD-
ANY FROM A MONTH OR MORE. AND
THAT THE MEDIA- BRENT YOU'RE A
AT. AT A MINIMUM HUNDRED OR.
YOU'RE DONE OKAY. BUT WILL NOW
HEAR FROM SENATOR MEN. I THANK
YOU SO MUCH I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING- STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF MEASURES TO TRY
TO PROVIDE RELIEF TO THOSE
STRUGGLING DURING THIS COMPANY
KANEMI IS CRITICAL IN MY VIEW
THAT WE PROVIDE A LIFELINE TO
THOSE STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR
RENTS AND ALSO THE SMALL
LANDLORDS WHO ARE RELYING ON
THAT INCOME- FOR THEIR OWN
LIVELIHOODS BECAUSE THIS
DOWNTURN SO. I'M A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS GENERAL
APPROACH AND APPRECIATE THE
HARD WORK THAT WENT INTO THIS
IS CLEARLY GOT A LOT OF
DETAILED PLANNING THAT YOU PUT
INTO IT SO THANK YOU FOR THAT-
I DO HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS I
JUST WANTED TO ASK- SO FIRST AS
SOME OF MY CONSTITUENTS ARE
SMALL LANDLORDS. WHO TOLD ME
THAT THERE TENANTS HAVE STOPPED
COMMUNICATING WITH THEM QUICKLY
NOW YOUR PROPOSAL DEALS WITH
LANDLORDS WHO WON'T COOPERATE
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL- BUT AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THERE'S NO
PROVISIONS FOR THE REVERSE AT
UA ATION WHERE'S THE TENANTS
THAT MAY NOT BE COOPERATING-
pWOULD YOU BE WILLING TO
CONSIDER MEASURES TO DEAL WITH
THAT SITUATION WHERE. FOR
WHATEVER REASON IT'S A TENANT
THAT IS NOT SIGNING THE
DOCUMENTS THAT ARE NECESSARY.
TO BUY FOR THIS RENTAL
ASSISTANCE. HER AND I AS I
SAID- EARLIER THE- PROGRAM IS
REALLY GEARED- TRANSACTIONS
WITH LANDLORDS- AND- WE DID I
GAVE THE EXAMPLE OF A TENANT.
APPLY BEHALF OF THE LAND LED BY
I THINK YOU'RE AT ABOUT THE
UPBEAT BE OPPOSITE OF THAT. AND
I I'M NOT I MEAN IT'S PUSHED
OVER TO AGENCIES I'M NOT A SURE
THAT. WOULD BE AGAIN THIS
PROGRAM IS MEANT AND HE MORE TO
A PLAN AND OF THAT'S- THE- ON
OF TIME. BUT WOULD IT WE NEED A
SOME A IS A THAT CORRECT IN SO
THE TENANTS WOULD HAVE TO
COOPER SO I YOU'RE PROPOSAL
CORRECTLY CONTEMPLATES. WHERE
THE PLAN SERVICE TO QUASH.
RIGHT NAY FUSED INTO THIS- THAT
FOR. I'M ASKING THE WHAT IF THE
APPLIES WITH THE IS NOT COOPER.
I UNDERSTAND IS YOU NEED
TENANTS. ON SOMETHING TO GET
THEIR RELIEF- SO ARE THERE
MEASURE YOU MIGHT. FOR THAT
SITUATION. AND WOULD YOU BE ONE
TO CONSIDER. YEAH THANK YOU A
QUEST PLEASE. YES SENATOR ON
THE- THINK ARE ARE HANDS REALLY
BIT TIME WITH THE FRONT LAND
LEGISLATION IN TERMS OF REQUIRE.
THE LAND THE TENANT PARTICIPATE-
BUT TO ACCOUNT FOR. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE STE. IS
THIS CAN YOU BASED APPROACH WE-
THE- AND- WOULD BE. WITH LOCAL
ORGANIZED SUPPRESSED THROUGH OR-
AND WE WOULD FACTOR WE WHICH-
OUT. AND WE WOULD- SIR NUMBER.
OUR REGION. TO BE ABLE- KIND.
THE TIME I- TO BE ABLE TO. ITS
THE TIME OF THE- THE BILL COME.
THE HELP BE ABLE TO. ANY DOC.
THAT THEY- THAT THEY WOULD TO
BE. TO JUST. AND IN THE PRO.
AND- THAT WOULD BE PART THE
PROGRAM. ROLE OF THE HELPING
INCREASE THE UPTAKE- BUT IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO. WORK
RECALL- CAN OF THE ADULT JUST-
THAT THE FEDERAL LIKE LET'S
JUST. I'M NOT A LOT FOR THEM. I
THANK YOU FOR MUCH FOR THAT
MAKE MY SICK QUESTION- I WANT
TO FOLLOW ON WHAT'S- CORKER IN
OTHER WERE SAYING. ABOUT JUSTIN.
OF RULINGS OUT OF FISHING AND
GET THE MONEY OUT QUICKLY. TWO
MILLION MY CONSTITUENTS RIGHT
NOW HAVE LOST FAITH IN STATE
GOVERNMENT DUE TO A- FAILURE IS
IT WOULD ET WHICH- I WILL NOT.
WITH THE- WILL. I SAW IT IS- A
GOOD FOR ME TO HEAR EXCHANGE
EARLIER. AROUND OF THE MEASURE
YOU ALL ARE CAN. WITH THE- PLAN
AND OTHER. TO MAKE SURE. THAT
ACTS WILL BE THE THAT YOU'RE
FOR OVERFLOW THAT'S COME. AND I
FOR- ERICA ANSWER OF MY COURSE
OF WHERE THE FOR WOULD COME
FROM- BY POINTING OUT THAT
FIRST. UP 2% INCOME FOR THE
FEDERAL ASSIST. I GUESS MY
QUESTION WOULD TALK ABOUT A MAN.
ROLLOUT THAT NEEDS TO I THE LAW
IN A FEW WEEKS AND SCHEDULE.
AND SO QUESTION IS DO YOU YOU
NEED MORE ASSIST FROM THE- I DO
MORE. FIND FROM. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT NGUYEN H. D. ROLE IS
OUT. IT IS YOU KNOW READY TO
THAT WAY NOT PROP OF THE THAT
HAVE TO ME ROLLOUTS OF THIS
TYPE. I AT THE STATE LEVEL IN
IN RECENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
SENTIMENT FOR THAT. THE ONE
THING I WHICH I LIKE TO SAY IS
THAT. WE ARE TRYING TO. UP ON
THE COMPLETELY NEW PROGRAM I
MEAN THIS IS A- WIDE RENTAL.
PROGRAM YES. BUT WE ARE TRYING
TO. WITH THE LOCAL. THAT HAVE
ARE BEEN IN EXISTENCE. PURSUANT
TO SOME OF THAT CARRIED OUT.
DOLLARS THEY WERE RISK.
ADDITIONALLY MY COLLEAGUES AND
AGENCY UPSET. IT THEY ARE DAVE
ARE STARTED. ON- PROCURE. OF
THIRD. EMPLOYEE SOLO OF- UNDER-
AUTHORITY TO SO I THINK A LOT
OF THE- THAT NEED TO HAVE.
QUICKLY ARE- BEING CONTENT. AND
WE'RE TRYING TO STREAMLINE. OUR
STATE. SO IT IS- ABLE TO. SOME
OF THE LOCAL. THAT IT'S ALREADY.
I WITHOUT WOULD ALSO. OF JUST
TO INVITE MIKE. DATA ELSE- IF I.
MET ANYTHING. I THANK YOU SO
FOR THE OFFER OF SUPPORT AND I
THINK WE THING THAT WOULD BE
REALLY. IMPORTANT AS AS THIS.
ROLE WILL OUT. HAVING- HAVING
LEADERS OF- HAVING LET JUST
SUPPORT IN TERMS OF PROMOTE THE
CON. AND HOW. AND JURISTIC AND
CAN- AT BE INFORMED BE AWARE
AND BE COMFORTABLE TO PROP. AND
I THINK IS GOING TO AN ALL ON
JACK TYPE OF PROGRAM SO HAVING
THAT- THAT LEADERSHIP SUPPORT
WILL BE. CALLS AT. SIX I TO BE
ONLY FROM. HERE BUT- I THINK
IT'S VERY AND THAT WE GET THIS
RIGHT- IN I'M- THEY I WOULD BE
WILLING TO CONQUER. IT IS FIND
FOR AIDS. FOR THE IF ROLE OF
THIS PRO. ASSEMBLY IN THE RULE
OF THREE AT THIS GOT ONE MORE
QUESTION FOR YOU ALL. I'M
TRYING TO. A LITTLE BIT MORE
HOW THE ROLE IS SUPPOSE TO PLAY
MY UNDERSTAND IS THAT. THE
FUNDING IS GONNA BE ALLAH. TO
COUNT. OR PROGRAM IMPLEMENTED.
BASED ON THEIR WORK FOR AS AS A
POP. BE FORMULA- TO BE
COMPLETED IN LATER THAN
FEBRUARY. OF THIS YEAR- WE CAN
ABA. TO DISPERSE ALL FINES BY
NO LATER THAN AUGUST FIRST- I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS HOW DOES
THAT COUNTY SPECIFIC BLOCK
GRANT. NOW ON YOUR- OF
PRIORITIES. YOU GET ROUNDS
PRIORITIES. BUT WHAT HAPPENS IS
IN COUNTY WHICH I REPRESENT FOR
EXAMPLE. WE HAVE MANY. IN THAT
50% AND IT'S NOT WE DON'T HAVE
NEARLY ENOUGH FUNDING. FOR
INTERNATIONAL NEEDS WHERE IS IN
PERHAPS A NEIGHBORING COUNTY I
DON'T KNOW MAN ANYONE WHO I'M
FOR EVERY. CLAIM WILL CLAIM
UNDER FUND. BUT BUT SUPPOSED
COUNTY- MEANWHILE HAS TOO MUCH
FUNDING IS THERE A WAY FOR. US
TO HAVE SOME. WHEN WE CAN GO
BACK BASED ON THE PRICE. ROUNDS
THAT YOU ALL HAS FOR- AND HOW
DO THIS HOUSE IS ALSO. TO PLAY
OUT WITH THE COUNTY BLAH
FUNDING- VISA BE THE ROUNDS
THAT YOU KIND OF ASPECTS OF. I
DON'T THINK WHAT MAKES SENSE.
YES AND I I'LL- AND THAT. FOR
THE. THANK YOU SENATE I AM SO
FOR THE FUNDING THAT IS GRANTS
OUT TO ADDRESS TO FROM THE
JURISTIC WHICH IS RISK FOR
IMPLEMENTING- IN THEIR- AND THE
IT WOULD BE IN A THE THOSE WITH
PRIOR SYSTEM AROUND- SO THAT
WOULD BE THAT WE BE THAT THE
TEST OF HOW PIECE WAS ADMIN-
FOR JURISDICTION THAT OFTEN
THIS PRO. AND WILL PUT THEIR
DIRECT I'M FUNDS THE PROBE. AS
AS THE- AS THE APPLICATIONS
COME AND THEY WOULD BE PAIRED
AGAINST THAT LOCATION- AND
THERE WOULD BE THAT THAT. ONE
OF THE GOALS OR IN EQUITY THERE
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE- THOSE
RESERVATIONS POOLS ARE FILLED
AND THAT THE- THE FUNDS GO TO
THOSE JURISDICTIONS- WE WOULD
SUSPECT THAT THERE WOULD BE IN
MANY CASES OVER SUBSCRIPTION
WHICH IS WHERE THAN THE
PRIORITIZATION OF BETWEEN
APPLICATIONS IN A JURISDICTION
COME INTO PLAY. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT I THINK IS THIS
WORTH INR FROM REPEATING AGAIN
IS. IS THIS CONCEPT THAT- AT
CERTAIN POINTS IN THE PROCESS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ABLE
TO. HOLD BACK FUNDS THAT BEEN
OBLIGATED. AND SO WE'VE
STRUCTURED- THIS PROGRAM TO
HELP WITH SIMILAR- JUST HAVE A
SIMILAR STRUCTURE AT THE STATE
LEVEL. WHERE FROM THE BLOCK
GRANTED FUNDING IF FUNDING IS
NOT OBLIGATED IT COULD BE HOLD
BACK INTO THE STATE CENTER AND
THEN REALLOCATING BASED OFF OF
DEMAND INTO THOSE EXISTING
RESERVATION POOLS. AND THEN- IN
THE. IN THE SAME WAY THE THOSE
THAT ARE ALREADY. THIS SYSTEM
AT A CERTAIN POINT WE WOULD
LOOK ACROSS AND WE WOULD SHIFT
AROUND- WE WOULD SHIFT AROUND
RESOURCES BETWEEN THE
RESERVATION HOLES. TO ACCOUNT
FOR DEMAND AND SHE MADE SURE
THAT WE COULD ALSO SEND DOWN
THE STATE RESOURCES. AND PUT
OURSELVES IN A POSITION TO
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING. AND SO I GUESS JUST TO
CUT TO THE CHASE- I WANT TO
JUST MAKE SURE THAT THE 50% OF
THOSE THAT ARE UNDER 50% AND I
WILL BE PRIORITISED ACROSS THE
STATE. IRRESPECTIVE OF REGIONAL
DIFFERENCES IN WHO GETS WHAT
FUNDING IS THAT IS THAT THE
SHORT VERSION OF WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. NOT COULD NOT QUITE- SO
IS STILL WE STILL ARE. WE STILL
HAVE THESE RESERVATIONS TO
ENSURE. THAT THE FUNDS ARE
GETTING DISTRIBUTION JUST
DISPERSED ON A GEOGRAPHIC
BASIS. AND SO THAT WOULD BE.
INTEL YOU GET TO THAT POINT
WHERE IN TIME WHERE I THINK I'D
HAVE TO CHECK AGAIN BUT I THINK
IT'S AROUND- JULY. UNTIL YOU
REACH THAT POINT THERE WOULDN'T
BE MOVEMENT BETWEEN THE BETWEEN
THE RESERVATION CALLS- IT WOULD
JUST BE PRIORITIZATION WITHIN
THE RESERVATION. HOWEVER AT
THAT TIME WHEN THEY WOULD BE
THE REDISTRIBUTION. CERTAINLY
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAD- HIGHER
NEEDS OF THE LOWER AIRLINE.
WOULD SEE MORE OF THOSE
RESOURCES REALLOCATED SHORT.
CIRCLE I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
I'M GOOD THERE THANK YOU US
SENATOR MEN SENATOR MCGUIRE.
BECAUSE OF THAT AND DO SHARE
YOUR YOUR YOUR MIKE'S NOT ON
YET. OKAY FRENCH FOR ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH MATTER
MEDICARE FIRST OFF I JUST WANT
TO SAY I THANK YOU TO THE
BUDGET YEAR TO THE PRO TEM THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE- BOTH HOUSES
THE LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT
CENTRE CABALLERO UP FOR ALL OF
THE WORK THAT WE NEED TO. HAVE
BRINGING IT IS CRITICAL
PROPOSAL FOR HERE TODAY-
THEY'RE JUST TO CLARIFYING
QUESTIONS I HAVE- VENTURE IF IT
WORKS FOR YOU ONE ON RURAL
COUNTIES THE SECOND ON MEDIUM
SIZE COUNTIES STATUS- IN ONE A-
I I'LL DIRECTORS TO MISLEAD
MISLI IF YOU WANT YOU CAN.
DIRECT IT OUT TO THE
APPROPRIATE INDIVIDUAL OR
ANSWER YOURSELF. SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE I AM GOOD ON THE
CADENCE FOR THE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION THAT WILL BE
DIRECTLY ALLOCATED FOR COUNTIES
LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION. TO MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT FUNDS WILL B MANAGED.
BY STATE SELECTED VENDOR. THE
DOLLARS WITHIN FOUR FROM THE
STATE'S VENDOR. TO LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS IN THOSE SMALLER
COUNTIES. WHO WERE WORKING ON
WHETHER IT'S TENET OR HOUSING
ISSUES. I WANNA IT JUST
CLARIFY. DOES THE STATE
ACTUALLY GRANT OUT THE MONEY OR
WITH THOSE LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS
WHO ARE ON THE GROUND GRANT OUT
THE MONEY. SENATE THE STATE
WOULD HOLD THE CONTRACT WITH
THAT- THIRD PARTY IMPLEMENTOR-
AND THE THIRD PARTY IMPLEMENTOR
WITH AND WORK WITH LOCALS IN
REGARDS TO THE DESTRUCTION OF
THOSE DOLLARS- IF YOU WANT.
FURTHER DETAIL I'D HAVE TO ASK
MY COLLEAGUE- LATER A NEED.
THAT YET BUT MY QUESTION ON
THAT OR SPIN THE PROCESS BUT
WHO WHO IS ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
GRANTED THE MONEY IS GONNA BE
THE STATE OR THE LOCAL
ORGANIZATION. YOU CAN TAKE. I'M
SUSPENDED THE GRANTING WOULD BE
DONE AT THE CENTRAL LEVEL BY
THE PROGRAM IMPLEMENTER- SO FOR
JIM TO BE ABLE TO AVOID
DUPLICATION OF BENEFITS- HELP
INCREASE FRAUD PREVENTION AND
ALSO INCREASE EFFICIENCIES IN
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
APPLICATION PORTAL AND THE
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS SO THAT
THE PHYSICAL TRANSFER OF MONEY
WHAT HAPPENED BY THE CENTRAL
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTER. THE
COMPONENT THAT WOULD BE-
HUNTING HELPS AND MANAGED
pTHE CURTAIN THE CARD NATION TO
BE ABLE TO GET APPLICANTS TO
APPLY INTO THAT CENTRAL PORTAL
IN ENERGY IN YOUR DEFINITION OF
THE CENTRAL PROGRAM- ORGANISERS.
IS THE- THE STATE'S SELECTED
VENDOR RIGHT IT'S GONNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE TALKING THE
SAME THING IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT THAT'S CORRECT. AND I'M
REALIZING I MIGHT WANNA MAKE
ONE MORE CLARIFICATION SURE IS
THAT IF IN A JURISDICTION-
OFFICE FOR BLOCK GRANTS AND
THEN THEY WOULD BE THE ONES WHO
WERE. DISTRIBUTING THAT THE
FUNDS SAID THE STATEMENT I JUST
MADE IS ONLY FOR THOSE OPT INTO
THE STATE PROGRAM CORRECT IF A
JURISDICTION TAKE CHOOSES A
BLOCK GRANTS THAN THEY WOULD BE
THE ONES WHO WOULD BE
ADMINISTERING THAT THE- THAT.
THE FUNDS LOCALLY HOW TO
PERSONALLY APPRECIATED SO THAT
THAT THAT'S A REALLY GOOD SEGUE
TO MY LAST QUESTION. SO FOR
COUNTIES THAT ARE- IN A
POPULATION OF 200-100-0400
NINETY NINE THOUSAND. THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE TO ASK EACH CD
ESSENTIALLY TO BE ABLE TO GET
PERMISSION TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THEIR- STRATEGY ON
THE BLOCK GRANTS. EVEN THOUGH
THIS JURISDICTION. OF ALREADY
BEEN ALLOCATED. DIRECT. DOLLARS
SIGNING GIVING EXAMPLE.
CINNAMON CAN. WILL RECEIVE FOR
MAY INJURY ALLOCATION. IF THEY
WANT TO BE ABLE TO RUN- THE
BLOCK GRANT PORTION OF THIS
FUNDING THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO GET THE BLESSING OF EIGHT CD
ON THE STRATEGIEN FORMULA. BUT
ANY COUNTIES FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ENOUGH. DON'T SO THEY
CAN ADVANCE THEIR OWN STRATEGY
WITH THEIR BLOCK GRANT
ALLOCATION SO I JUST WANT TO
GET A BETTER UNDERSTANDING ON
WHY THOSE COUNTIES TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND THE FOUR NINETY NINE
THOUSAND HAVE TO GET THE
BLESSING FROM A CD WHY CAN'T WE
JUST SAY ANYONE TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND UP. AS WE'RE DOING
IT CARRIES A FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR NOT CAN RUN THEIR
OWN PROGRAM. YEAH I'LL START
WITH THAT QUESTION AND HANDED
OVER TO A NEW WITH THE DETAILS.
AS I STATED EARLIER- PREVIOUS
ROUNDS AND CARROTS FUNDING DID
GO DOWN TO A STATE- THREE LOCAL
COUNTIES AND CITIES- BUT THOSE
WERE WITH POPULATIONS OF FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR MORE SO
THERE IS THE ASSUMPTION THAT
THEY HAVE- TAKING THOSE FUNDS
AND HAVE HAD. SOME TIME TO
ALLOCATE THROUGH THEIR LOCAL
RENTAL. ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS-
THERE'S NOT NECESSARILY THAT
INSURANCE WITH THOSE ENTITIES
THAT ARE SMALLER- AND SO THERE
IS THERE SOMETHING BUILT INTO-
PROVIDE. VERIFICATION ON THAT
BUT- IF I I'LL I'LL TURN IT
OVER. TO AMY FOR SOME DETAILS
THANK YOU. SURE GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR HELLO THERE- SO YES IS
ERICA WAS DESCRIBING- THINKING
OR THE INTENTION BEHIND THAT
WAS SIMPLY THAT- THE-
JURISDICTIONS IN THAT TWO
HUNDRED TO FOUR NINETY NINE
YEAH- SIZE- HAD NOT RECEIVED
PRIOR DOLLARS CRF FUNDING AND
SO THEY WERE UNLIKELY TO AND
YOU HAVE AN EXISTING PROGRAM-
AS ERICA WAS DESCRIBING SO WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THEY FELT
THEY HAD THE CAPACITY- TO
MANAGE THIS ESPECIALLY GIVEN
ALL THE OTHER ON DEMAND. BASED
ON LIKE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RIGHT
NOW WITH ENDEMIC- AND SO THAT'S
WHY THAT THERE IS FLEXIBILITY
BUILT IN- IF THEY WOULD LIKE
TO- AND- YOU KNOW IF THEY WOULD
LIKE THE STATE TO ADMINISTER
BOTH THEIR DIRECT ALLOCATION
AND THEIR STATE SHARE- THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE STATE.
PROGRAM CAN DO FOR THEM- TO
RELIEVE THEM OF THAT BURDEN AND
ALL OF THAT- YOU KNOW THE
VERIFICATION- AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REPORTING
RESPONSIBILITIES- SO THAT'S ONE
OPTION- IF THEY'D LIKE TO DO
THE BLOCK GRANT- THEN THAT IS-
REQUESTING THAT THEY CAN
DEMONSTRATE SOME. CAPACITY OR-
YOU KNOW APPROACHED FOR HOW
THEY INTEND TO DO THAT BASED ON
THE FACT THAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE
A PROGRAM IF THEY HAD A PROGRAM
THAT WOULD BE. A GREAT WAY OF
ESTABLISHING AT. ARMS IT IS SO
IT AND THEN THE OTHER THING I
WANTED TO JUST CLEAR MY CREE
THAT EVEN WITH THAT THE LARGE
JURISDICTIONS THERE ARE
EXPECTATIONS PLACED ON HOW
THOSE BLOCK GRANTS ARE. ARE
USED AND- AND SO THERE IS A
SIMILAR SET OF. EXPECTATIONS
AND RECORDING- AND ALL THE SAME
PARAMETERS APPLY FOR THE. TWO
HUNDRED TO FOUR NINETY NINE IN
THE FIVE HUNDRED. BLOCK OKAY.
THIRTY YEARS IN THE PER OF I'M
SORRY I WAS WHEN I LOOK AT IT
THIS ANALYSIS AND THEN JUST
DIGGING INTO THE DETAILS IT
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S TWO
DIFFERENT PARAMETERS BUT- BUT
YOU SEE THE SAME ANALYSIS
IMPRIMER SUPPLY REGARDLESS OF
THE CATEGORY OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND IN A POTENTIALLY AS
FAR AS THE VETTING YEAH YES.
GOT IT HEY I REALLY APPRECIATE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FROM HERE AND
THANK YOU TO- AGENCY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR
CLARIFYING QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SENATOR MAKAROV'S SENATOR DOLLY
NEXT AND THEN LET ME LOOK ON
THE FLOOR AGAIN SENATOR
RICHMOND OKAY SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT
QUESTION FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE- A SECOND SENATE-DISTRICT
WE SAW IT. AS JUST A RECENT
REPORT THAT TAKE CARES MANY
THAT YOU DID NOT GET- ALLOCATED
EVENLY TO THE RULE AREAS OF THE
STATE. AND SO IF THEY DON'T IF
THEY DIDN'T APPLY OR DON'T HAVE
THE MEANS TO APPLY FOR THE
CARES FUNDING BEFORE- THEY WERE
LEFT BEHIND IT SO I'M CONCERNED
THAT. THE SAME THING COULD
HAPPEN IN THESE AREAS WHERE THE
POPULATION IS- ONE NINETY NINE
AND BELOW SO COULD YOU EXPLAIN
HOW THOSE RULE AREAS. THAT
STILL HAVE THE SAME NEEDS VERY.
LOW INCOME DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- ARE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THESE RESOURCES-
BUT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE WE DID SEE THAT IN THE-
PP ALLEGATIONS THAT THERE WAS-
LIKE 50% LESS. SO IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS THAT I'D LIKE A LITTLE
MORE FOLLOW UP ON WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE BROUGHT UP. FROM THE
FROM THE LAST THE LAST SENATOR
THAT SPOKE. SHARE AND JUST ONE
THING I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS
THAT THERE IS A THERE IS AN
APPLE DISTRIBUTION IN REGARDS
TO- EVERY EVERY COUNTY
RECEIVING A SET AMOUNT- AND THE
SMALL AND GIRLS WILL. WOULD
RECEIVE A HUNDRED FIFTEEN
MILLION WHICH- IS IN AND OF
ITSELF TWICE WHAT THEY WOULD
NORMALLY RECEIVE IF YOU'RE JUST
LOOKING AT HER POPULATION-
CUTS. THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE THERE ARE A GREAT NEEDS
IN SMALLER RURAL COUNTIES AS
WELL AND THE CITY THAT ARE
LOCATED WITHIN THOSE COUNTIES-
I WILL DEFER TO AMY FOR ORLAND
FOR SPECIFIC DETAILS IN REGARDS
TO- OUTREACH. AND OTHER WAYS-
OF MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND THOSE AREAS ARE
RECEIVING INFORMATION. THAT
THEY NEED TO APPLY. YES I GOOD
AFTERNOON- BUILDING OFF OF WHAT
ERICA WAS JUST SAYING SO- FIRST
OF ALL IN- KIND OF
CONTEMPLATING HOW THAT MONEY
IS. SPENT THERE WAS A LOT OF
INTENTIONALITY AROUND ASSURING
THAT- THE SMALLER JURISDICTIONS
UNDER TWO HUNDRED- THOUSAND
WERE- MAKE SURE THAT. THERE WAS
AMPLE FUNDING AVAILABLE TO
SERVE THOSE POPULATIONS THE
LANDLORDS AND TENANTS IN THIS
POPULATION- WHAT ERICA SAID THE
DOUBLING OF THE POPULATION
BASED- ALLOCATIONS FOR THOSE
AREAS- AND THEN- I WOULD AND
THEN AS TESTS AND- DESCRIBED.
ALSO THE- THOSE FUNDS WILL BE
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THEM THE
STATE PROGRAM THROUGH THE-
PROGRAM IMPLEMENTER THE VENDOR
THAT IS GOING TO BE CONTRACTED-
AND I WOULD SAY HERE. THIS IS
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
OUTREACH- IS SUCH A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF THIS CONTRACT
THAT- WE WILLBE- SECURING WITH
A THIRD PARTY IMPLEMENTED TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE- SOME.
EXTENSIVE NETWORKS. IN ALL
AREAS OF THE STATE OR HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO- EXPAND THE ONES
THAT THEY ALREADY HAVE- THEM SO
THAT. AND THEN THEN THE REGULAR
DATA COLLECTION- AND REPORTING
IS ALSO A CRITICAL COMPONENT TO
ASSURE THAT WE NEED TO MAKE.
ADJUSTMENTS IN HOW AT REACHES
OCCURRING IF WE SEE- YOU KNOW.
DIFFERENCES YOU KNOW WE'RE IN
IN MODOC COUNTY OVER- WE'RE
DOWN ORDER WHEREVER IT IS
INTERESTING AT CERTAIN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES THERE'S ACTIVITY
OTHERS ARE NOT. AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS ON
TARGETED OUTREACH WE NEED TO
ACTIVATE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TRUSTED
INTERMEDIARIES- TO ABOUT THAT
PROGRAM PARTICIPATION. THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT AND WE'RE SETTING HIGH
EXPECTATIONS FOR OUR PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTER TO FOLLOW. THROUGH
ON THAT EXPECTATION. WHAT WOULD
BE FINE IF THE IRA. THE LARGE.
SENATE DISTRICT G. IN THIS
WHERE WOULD I FOR A THIRD
VALLEY PARTY I COULD SEND MY
VOICE COUNTIES LIKE MODOC
COUNTY U. S. NINETY FIVE
HUNDRED PEOPLE IN IT WHERE
WOULD I SEND THEM IF TO GET
THAT INFORMATION. TO MAKE SURE
THEY DON'T GET LEFT BEHIND. SO
WE WOULD BE DOING- AS YOU NO
ROBUST OUTREACH EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
JUST IS NOT JUST. OR YOU KNOW
IT'S GOING TO BE THROUGHOUT
SOCIAL MEDIA THROUGHOUT AND YOU
KNOW THE MOVIE RADIO OR TV ALSO
SO PEOPLE ARE AWARE THAT- THESE
AT THIS PROGRAM EXISTS- SO.
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL BE KIND OF
FILTERING AND SOME INTERNET
ACTIVITY AROUND IT PEOPLE WILL
START TO ENSURE THE PROGRAM BUT
THEN THERE'S ALSO FROM THE
STATE DOWNWARD INTO THE
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING TO BE
ACTIVATING ARE USING. AND YOU
KNOW AND LIKE I SAID TRUSTED
INTERMEDIARIES WHETHER THEY ARE
THE YOU KNOW- I'M TRYING TO
THINK OF CIVIC ASSOCIATIONS
CHURCHES- YOU KNOW COMMUNITY
GROUPS THAT ARE KNOWN WERE ALSO
BE PARDONING PARTNERING
CERTAINLY WASTE- YOU KNOW C.
SACK AND LEAGUE- ALSO WITH
CERTAINLY A LANDLORD AND TENANT
ASSOCIATIONS- IT'S ON THE
GROUND TO KNOCK. ON DOORS IF
WE'RE HAVING A HARD TIME.
EATING IN SIR- CERTAIN- AND-
CENTER I CAN CERTAINLY- FOLLOW
UP YOU KNOW WE I ALSO ENVISION
ON THE LEGISLATIVE DEPUTY OR
AGENCY AND I. CERTAINLY
ENVISIONED THAT WILL BE- A LOT
OF EDUCATION DISTRICT OFFICE.
SO THAT- PEOPLE UNDERSTAND. THE
OPPORTUNITIES ABOUT THE RIGHTS
AND PROTECTIONS OF THE
MORATORIUM EXTENSION BUT ALL OF
THE- THAT RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM AND- YOU KNOW I'LL BE
WORKING WITH- THIS TO. BLOW
INFORMATION TO TRAININGS THAT-
DISTRICT OFFICES- CAN ALSO
SERVE AS AMBASSADORS. I WOULD I
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE THAT I.
JUST WOULD SHARE WITH YOU THAT.
I HAVE VERY LITTLE CONFIDENCE
IN THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT THINGS VERY WELL IN
THE AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE I MEAN WE ARE FIELDING
LITERALLY THOUSANDS OF CALLS
AND E. D. DE RIGHT NOW. AND
WE'VE BEEN IN THIS PROCESS FOR
TEN MONTHS IS THERE NOT SOME
WEBSITE THAT LOCALS ACROSS THE
STATE AS A MATTER WHAT DISTRICT
AND COULD GO TO GRAB THIS
INFORMATION TO FIND OUT. WHERE
THERE WOULD BE SO IF YOU'RE A
RENTER IN NO MATTER WHERE
YOU'RE AT. YOU CAN BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THAT BESIDES HAVE TO
CALL THEIR CENTER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WHAT
THOSE ITEMS ARE I CAN IMAGINE A
CHURCH YOU MENTIONED THE- FAITH
BASED COMMUNITY DOING THAT
MAYBE THERE'S NON PROFITS OUT
THERE THAT DO SOME OF THIS I
KNOW THAT THAT. THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THOSE FOLKS ARE
GONNA DEFINITELY BE REACHING
OUT TO THOSE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
THEIR THAT ARE IN THEIR
ASSOCIATIONS BUT NOT EVERY
RENTER BELONGS TO AN
ASSOCIATION THAT. QUITE FRANKLY
PROBABLY VERY FEW OF THEM DO SO
I I'M JUST LOOK I'LL BE HAPPY
TO GET INFORMATION SO I CAN
SHARE IT ON FACEBOOK AND ALL
THOSE THINGS OF SOCIAL MEDIA WE
HAVE BY THE END OF THE DAY- I
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF CALIFORNIANS THAT BEHIND A
LOT OF THESE PROCESSES ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT SO- I WOULD
WELCOME SOME LANDING PAGE
SOMEWHERE. THAT ALLOWS READERS
IN AND YOU KNOW THE OWNERS OF
THE BUILDINGS ON THE OTHER SIDE
TO BE ABLE TO YOU KNOW GET
INFORMATION SO THEY CAN ACCESS-
THESE FEDERAL DOLLARS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THAT FEET.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY SENATOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
EVERYBODY FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
HAS BEEN DONE AS HAVE THREE
BRIEF THINGS ONE AND I THINK
THAT'S A LOT OF WHICH YOU
HEARING AT TEN MONTHS INTO THIS
WORLD PRETTY EXHAUSTED AND OUR
AND OUR STAFF OFFICES ARE VERY
EXHAUSTED FROM THE AMOUNT. OF
CALLS A DAY OF THE FIELD WITH
WITH VERY LITTLE. WITH VERY
LITTLE INFORMATION BEING ABLE
TO GIVE TO PEOPLE RIGHT THE
WEATHER TDD WHETHER IT'S
VACCINES. ANY ANY OF THESE
THINGS RIGHT SO WHICH IS IT
JUST CONTINUES TO COMPOUND. AND
SO I THINK PEOPLE HAVE. HAVING
A HARD TIME HAVING FAITH THOSE WHO ARE TRYING TO GIVE
HOPE- AND CERTAINLY THOSE WHO
ARE WHO ARE CALLING OUR OFFICES
AND WERE EVEN MORE FRUSTRATED.
SO JUST TO SAY THAT THAT I MEAN.
THE SRVER THIRD BIG THING
WE'RE GONNA DO SO LET'S JUST
MAKE SURE WE DO IT WELL- THE
OTHER THING IS. SO WE HAVE BEEN
INTERACTING BOOK THROUGH THE
CARRIER'S MONEY AND WITH
EVERYBODY DO WE DO WE HAVE ANY
KIND OF IDEA ABOUT HOW MANY
MORE PEOPLE WILL BE APPLYING.
FOR THIS OR IS IT ALREADY THOSE
WHO ARE ALREADY IN THE-
INTERDICTION MORATORIUM ALREADY.
SECOND QUESTION AND THEN MY
THIRTIES JUST ARE WE DOING
ENOUGH FOR MORTGAGE- A LOT OF
THESE FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN PAID
WHO ARE STILL SITTING ON
MORTGAGES AND COMING DO ARE WE
DOING ENOUGH. AND THIS IS BILL.
ENVISION US DOING ENOUGH TO
HELP THEM. HI YES I AM SO JUST.
A QUICK FOLLOW UP ON YOUR FIRST
POINT- CENTER AND MEN AND ALSO
CENTER DOLLIES WE WAIT THERE IS
ACTUALLY A WEBSITE. CALLED
HOUSING IS KEY AND THAT'S UP
AND RUNNING AND THAT IS- GOING
TO BE THAT SORT OF A LANDING
SPOT THAT- FOODS CAN GO TO FOR
ASSISTANCE IN TERMS OF.
INFORMATION SO JUST WANTED TO-
POINTED OUT TO THE GROUP- IN
REGARDS TO. YOUR YOUR QUESTION-
I'M MORTGAGE- OWNERS. AND THIS
F- WHAT. AB AT WOULD ACTUALLY
DO IS EXTEND THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR HOMEOWNERS
RELATED TO MORTGAGE FORBEARANCE
FOR CLASS THAT WAS ALREADY
EMBEDDED IN AB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT AND THAT'S THOSE ARE
THINGS SUCH AS REQUIRING
LENDERS PROVIDING DETAILED
EXPLANATION. FOR ANY DENIAL OF
HER PARENTS ARE PROVIDING THE
HOMEOWNER TWENTY ONE DAYS TO
CORRECT ANY MISSING INCORRECT
INFORMATION ON THE REQUEST SO A
LOT OF WITHIN THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT IS ALSO. BEING EXTENDED
THROUGH- THIS TRAILER BILL. AND
I'M SORRY TODAY. BUT AS FAR AS
FAR AS WE KNOW THERE'S NO
ISSUES WITH THAT THAT HAS BEEN
THAT HAS BEEN WE HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM FROM- MORTGAGE HOLDERS.
ANYTHING DIFFERENT- I DON'T
KNOW IF I CAN ANSWER THAT
QUESTION I DON'T KNOW IF
AGENCY- YOU HAVE MORE
INFORMATION IN REGARDS TO
FEEDBACK. THIS IS A NEAT- GOOD
AFTERNOON US SENATOR I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT- MOST MORTGAGES
ARE FEDERALLY BACKED MORTGAGES
AND- SO THOSE ARE FALL UNDER
THE FEDERAL PROTECTIONS FOR
FORBEARANCE- AND SO MANY
HOMEOWNERS- BORROWERS ARE
AVAILING THEMSELVES OF THOSE
PROTECTIONS FOR- EXTENSIONS- A-
FORBEARANCE- UNDER THOSE
PROTECTIONS AND THEN THIS
STATE. AS ERICA MENTIONED- THE
STATE LEVEL CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS- KIND OF SUPPLEMENT
THAT- IF FOR SOME REASON THERE
IS A DENIAL OF A FORBEARANCE I
REQUEST. THE BILL DOES- INCLUDE
A CERTAIN- OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE DAY. THE HOMEOWNER TO- YOU
KNOW CORRECT AND- REAPPLY FOR
THE FORBEARANCE IN GAMES AND
RECONSIDERATION OF THAT PROCESS.
YEAH AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT
ABOUT 70% OF- MORTGAGE
FORBEARANCE IS FEDERALLY BACKED
SO THAT'S A LARGE CHUNK OF
THOSE- PEOPLE WHO WOULD HAVE-
ISSUE TRYING TO HELP THE- I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE LYNN COULD
SPEAK TO THE NATIONAL MORTGAGE
SETTLEMENT FUNDS WHICH IS
ANOTHER SOURCE OF SUPPORT AND
THAT WITH THE STATE HAS. FOR
HOMEOWNERS RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU
MAY I AM YES THE COMPANY
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY KELLY
TRIVEDI HAS LAUNCHED- A SUPPORT
PROGRAM THEM USING NATIONAL
MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT FUNDS IT'S
CHU FACES THE FIRST IS ONGOING
NOW AND THAT IS PROVIDING
HOUSING COUNSELING SERVICES AND
TO HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE ON AT
RISK OF FORECLOSURE- AND- THE
SECOND PHASE OF THAT IS GETTING
READY TO LAUNCH AS WELL IN THE
ABSTRACT MORTGAGE ASSISTANCE-
TO HOUSEHOLDS THAT THAT THAT
ARE AT RISK OF FORECLOSURE AND
SO THAT WOULD BE ABLE THEM
SINGLE FAMILY AND- AND-
LANDLORDS TENANTS- PROPERTIES.
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WILL BE DOING HAS IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS PROGRAM IS A
SWASTIKA POSSIBLE IS IF
SOMEBODY WHO MAY NOT BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WITHIN AN
APPLICATION WHERE THEY WOULD BE
MORE ELIGIBLE FOR STATE THE
MORTGAGE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
THAT WE WOULD HAVE A REFERRAL
STRUCTURE SO THAT WE CAN BE
ABLE TO MAKE THAT CONNECTION
I'M TO GET THE TO GET. A
HOUSEHOLD TO THE TO THE RIGHT
PLACE. FOR ANY DO WE HAVE ANY
AYE. ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO
ALREADY AVAILING THEMSELVES TO
THIS TO THE TO THE- EVICTION
MORATORIUM ARE THERE GONNA BE A
BUNCH MORE THAT ARE GOING TO
APPLY OR IS IT IS IT IT'S THE
SAME MOSTLY THE SAME GROUP
THEY'RE ALREADY TALKING ABOUT.
ENGINE TAKEN- YOU RESPOND TO
THAT QUESTION. SERVICE CENTER
MY- MY SECTION WOULD BE WITH
THE EVICTION MORATORIUM IT
WOULD JUST MAINTAIN BECAUSE IT
MAINTAINS THE PROTECTIONS THAT
ARE IN PLACE- I NOT- I BELIEVE
THAT IT WOULD PROBABLY BE ABOUT
THE SAME POPULATION THERE MAY
BE SOME- NEW. AND NEW TENANTS
THAT ARE EXPERIENCING COULD BE
RELATED TO- HARDSHIPS AND WOULD
NEED TO SUBMIT THE- THAT
DECLARATION TO THEIR LANDLORD-
AND THIS WOULD ENABLE THEM TO
DO THAT- IF THEY ARE IF THEY
MAYBE MORE RECENTLY HAVE
EXPERIENCED- A HARDSHIP THAT
THEY MORE EXPERIENCED LAST
YEAR- THIS BILL CREATES THE
CONTINUITY THOUGH FOR THOSE-
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN IN
DURING- AND STRUGGLING THROUGH
THIS PERIOD. SINCE ALMOST A
YEAR NOW. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR EGGMAN LET ME SEE THE
FIRE THOSE MEMBERS WHO WANTED
TO ASK QUESTIONS. YES OKAY I
HAVE JUST A COUPLE BEFORE WE
OPEN UP AGAIN TO OR NOT AGAIN
BUT BEFORE WE OPEN TO THE
PUBLIC MIGHT. PUBLIC COMMENT-
SO MY FIRST QUESTION IS- THIS
THIS IS DEPENDENT ON A
STATEWIDE ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE
STATE PORTION OF THE FUNDS HAVE
WE IDENTIFIED ALREADY WHO WILL
BE PERFORMING THIS FUNCTION. I
BELIEVE- EITHER LYNN OR ANY
CORRESPOND TO THAT IN DETAIL.
SENATOR WE HAVE CONDUCTED
EXTENSIVE MARKET RESEARCH- AND
HAD AN EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH VENDORS- THAT TODAY HOUSES
THE TECHNICAL KEEP ABOUT
CAPABILITY TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
WORK THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED- BUT
WE HAVE NOT ENTERED INTO A
CONTRACT- NO WILL WE INSTALL
THAT THE BILL IS AN ACTIVE.
RIGHT SIR BUT THE- THE EFFORT
IS ALREADY UNDERWAY TO FIND
SOMEONE HAVE SOME AN ENTITY
THAT IS OR ENTITIES. CAPABLE OF
A- OF HANDLING DESERVE FULL
FUNCTION OF THIS. YES SENATOR
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY- I THINK.
THERE ARE THE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE RAISED. OBVIOUSLY THERE'S-
HOW I INTERPRET THESE IS THAT
WE ARE WE WANT. WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE MANY TENANTS UNDER
EXTREME ECONOMIC PRESSURE RIGHT
NOW WE DO NOT WANT TO SEE A
WAVE OF HOMELESSNESS WE KNOW
THAT MANY OF THEIR LANDLORDS
ARE ALSO UNDER EXTREME ECONOMIC
PRESSURE AND WE DO NOT WANT TO
A FURTHER BURDEN THEM OR TO
HAVE THEM MOTIVATED TO GET RID
OF TENANTS BECAUSE- THAT IS NOT
THE KIND OF SITUATION WE WANT
TO BE IN RIGHT NOW WHEN WE
ALREADY HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS
THAT WAS WELL UNDERWAY EVEN
PRIOR TO COBIT. SO HOW ARE HERE
THIS IS THAT. AND OF COURSE WE-
WILL SEE ALL OF WHAT'S GOING
ALL BIT IS THAT THERE IS- WITH
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
BE A PARTNER WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THIS AND THAT
WE WANT TO SEE IT SUCCEED. AND
THAT THE QUESTIONS WE'VE BEEN
ASKING OUR TO HELP ENSURE THAT
WE SUCCEED AND WE SUCCEED
SMOOTHLY. AND SO THAT WE DON'T
ADD EITHER FURTHER HEADACHE ON
THE PART OF OUR CONSTITUENTS ON
SAID I THINK THERE'S AN
APPRECIATION THAT EVERYTHING WE
HAVE UNDERTAKEN IN THIS
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN COMPLICATED.
DIFFICULT HI THERE ARE STRESSES
UNDER SO MANY BUSINESS SECTORS
INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES THE
GOVERNMENT ITSELF DUE TO THIS
PANDEMIC. THAT NOTHING IS EASY
BUT AS MUCH AS WE CAN. DESIGN
THE SYSTEMS SO THAT THEY ARE
WORKING. I'LL USE JUST AGAIN
THAT SIMPLY EFFICIENTLY AND OF
COURSES FRAUD PROOF AS POSSIBLE.
AND AS MUCH AS WE CAN USE
EXISTING STRUCTURES ALL THE
BETTER AND I THINK MANY OF US.
LIVE IN REGIONS WHERE THERE ARE
EXISTING FERRY FUNCTIONAL AND
ROBUST EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS. AND WE
KNOW THAT THE FUNDING THAT'S
GOING DIRECTLY TO THE LARGE
CITIES THAT NEW LIKELY IN LARGE
COUNTIES THEY'LL LIKELY USE
THEIR EXISTING PROGRAM IF THEY
HAVE ONE BUT IT WOULD BE WISE
FOR THE STATE TO ALSO LOOK AT
THOSE EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT
ARE OPERATING RIGHT NOW AND
A PARTNER WITH THEM
APPROPRIATELY TO ASSIST US IN
THIS TASK- ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
I HAVE IS THAT WHILE I THINK
THIS IS WELL DESIGNED. TO
MOTIVATE LANDLORDS TO
PARTICIPATE WHICH IS OF COURSE
WE WOULD BE DEPENDENT ON.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE ALREADY
MORE ALL RIGHT ALWAYS MARKET
FORCES THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
MOTIVATE A LANDLORD NOT TO. AND
IN THOSE AREAS THOSE REGIONS
THAT HAVE FOR EXAMPLE VERY
STRONG RENT CONTROLS AND IF
THERE ARE LANDLORDS WHO'VE
BEEN. ALL JUST- YOU KNOW I'VE
BEEN WANTING TO. RID THEMSELVES
OF TEN X. OR Y. FOR SOME TIME
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT UNDER
THE STATE'S VACANCY DE CONTROL
LAWS THAT THE- THE RENT THAT
THEY MAY BE ABLE TO GET WITH
THE NEW TENANT MIGHT BE A GOOD
DEAL HIGHER. I THINK THAT WE
WANT TO MAKESURE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WE WANT TO MONITOR THIS
BECAUSE WE DO NOT WANT TO
CREATE. THAT CONTEXT WHERE
BECAUSE THIS IS A VOLUNTARY
THAT THERE'S SOME NUMBER THAT
DON'T PARTICIPATE AND THUS WE
FACE ANOTHER INFLUX OF EVICTION
ACTIONS THAT REALLY PUT US IN.
IT AS WE KNOW IT IS SO MUCH
HARDER TO DEAL WITH A HOUSING
SITUATION AFTER SOMEONE IS
INFECTED SO IF WE CAN KEEP
PEOPLE HOUSE THAT HAS GOT TO BE
OUR OBJECTIVE- SO WITH THAT I
FEEL LIKE. THIS IS- WE'VE GOT A
GOOD INITIAL STRUCTURE THERE
ARE PROBABLY SOME THINGS THAT
COULD YOU KNOW COULD BE TWEAKED
AND WE HAVE SOME TIME BEFORE
BETWEEN NOW AND ONE INDEX AND I
DON'T EAN BETWEEN WHEN IT
EXPIRES OBVIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA
BE MONITORING THIS BUT WHERE WE
MAY SEE A NECESSITY TO TWEAK.
AND I WOULD ALSO JUST REYES
QUICKLY THAT FROM WHAT I AM
VERY GLAD TO THE BILL WASN'T
PRINT AS OF YESTERDAY AND THAT
WE HAVE AN ANALYSIS AND THAT WE
WILL NOT BE VOTING ON THE FLOOR
UNTIL THURSDAY HOWEVER WE ALSO
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW EVEN IN MY
BEST BILLS THAT WENT THROUGH
EVERY COMEDIAN EVERY PROCESS
THAT WE FOUND IN CHAPTER RING
FOR EXAMPLE THAT WE HAD SOME
TECHNICAL FIXES TO MAKE. SO
THERE MAY BE AND LIKELY WILL BE
SOME TECHNICAL FIXES ARE
DRAFTING ERRORS BUT WE WILL
HAVE TIME TO ADDRESS THOSE AS
WE REALIZE THEM AND- AND NOT
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT. NOT ACTING
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE A DEADLINE
FOR OUR EXISTING MORATORIUM. SO
WITH THAT LET'S GO TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL FIRST
CHECK AND SEE WHETHER WE HAVE
ANYONE IN THE PUBLIC HEARING
ROOMS MY UNDERSTANDING WAS
THERE WAS NOT. THE CORRECT.
OKAY THEN- WE WILL GO TO THE-
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM. AND
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS KNOW
THE- NUMBER THE PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 844-291-6364 THE
ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT SEVEN SIX
EIGHT NINE FOUR ONE. AND I AM
GOING TO ASK THOSE PROVIDING
COMMENTS ON. BEACHES ST I WILL
KEEP YOU TO A MINUTE AND- I DO
NOT WANT TO LOSE VERY IMPORTANT
POINTS SO IF YOU HAVE SOME VERY
SPECIFIC POINTS TO BRING TO
YOUR ATTENTION WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOUR- GETTING TO
THOSE RIGHT AWAY. AND- A
MODERATOR CAN YOU PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT WILL BEGIN. SURE
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. I WOULD
LIKE TO. GO TO OUR FIRST
COMMENT FROM LINE TEN LINE TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALIFORNIA
BUDGET DURING SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSAL WANTED TO PRACTICE
SAYING COMPLETE CREATIONS OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. FOR PUTTING THE
PROPOSAL TOGETHER TO ENSURE
THAT THE- FOUR MILLION RENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA WHO ARE FACING
AFFECTION PRIOR TO JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST ARE NOT GOING TO
HAVE TO LIVE WITH BACK ON GOING
FEAR IN THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE.
THERE IS ONGOING WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE YEAH- TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S BETTER
PARENTAL EQUITY AND THAT THE
LOOPHOLE. EXISTING IN BOTH
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT AND THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU CAN BE
BETTER ADDRESSING TO MAKE SURE
THAT- NEFARIA. YOU KNOW
UNDERTAKINGS DON'T FURTHER HER
RENTER'S. AND YOU LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
IN THE FUTURE ON THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND MODERATOR WE GO
TO THE NEXT COLOR CAN YOU TELL
ME HOW MANY- SPEAKERS WE HAVE
LINED UP. WE CURRENTLY HAVE-
FIFTEEN FIFTEEN OKAY EXCELLENT
I'M SORRY WE WILL CONTINUE GO
AHEAD. I DO DIRECTORS THIRTY
TWO TWO DROPPED AND NOW TO LINE
THIRTY EIGHT LINE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- THIS
IS MOIRA TALK ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO AND MERRICK
TODD GLORIA WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE AND VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THE
LEGISLATURE INDIAN INSTRUCTION
PUT INTO THIS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIR ROSS
BUCKLEY ON BEHALF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT OF AB AT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NOW TO LINE FORTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MADAM
CHAIR JACKIE GRAY WHAT WITH THE
F. B. W. WESTERN STATE COUNCIL
SEEKING ON BEHALF OF OUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THOUSAND
FRONT LINE UP W. MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA I KNOW TODAY'S
DISCUSSION WAS AROUND- TENANT
RELIEF HOWEVER WE DO YOU WANNA-
THE LEGISLATURE TO PRIORITIZE
EMERGENCY PAID SICK LEAVE AND
ANY BUDGET ITEM THAT MOVE
FORWARD- ON JANUARY FIRST
DURING THE HIGH INSURGENTS HAVE
IN NINETEEN CASES IN CALIFORNIA
AND WITH THE DISCOVERY OF A NEW
MORE CONTAGIOUS STRAIN OF THE
VIRUS. WORKERS LOST THEIR
ABILITY TO ACCESS EMERGENCY
PAID SICK LEAVE A CRITICAL
THINKING NOT THAT ALLOWS
WORKERS PARTICULARLY LOW WAGE
MINORITY WORKERS TO STAY HOME
IF THEY'RE EXPOSED TO CONTRACT
FOR THE NINETEEN WORKERS NEED
EMERGENCY PAID SICK LEAVE NOW
MORE THAN EVER I MEAN FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDE LANGUAGE
IN THE BUDGET THAT PROVIDE ALL
WORKERS ADDITIONAL PAID SICK
LEAVE. WORKERS ARE LIVING
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK AND ARE
ONE PAYCHECK AWAY FROM LOSING
THEIR HOMES THEIR CARS THEIR
ABILITY TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE EVERYTHING. CAN BE PAID
SICK LEAVE AS THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A WORKER BEING ABLE TO
STAY HOME TO PROTECT THEIR CO
WORKERS FROM EXPOSURE HAVING TO
GO TO WORK BECAUSE THEY NEED
INCOME AN IMPOSSIBLE SITUATION
TO BE FOR AN- I WOULD STRONGLY
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT
EMERGENCY PAID SICK LEAVE
PROVISION THAT ANY IMMEDIATE
BUDGET THAT MOVE. WITHOUT THESE
WORKERS ARE LEFT WITH NO
PROTECTION I. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW TO LINE. FOR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI AFTERNOON
MY IS NOT ON THE ON WITH THE
WORK REACHED CENTER I'M ALL
RECEIVED THE NOW FOR ALL CALL.
FINALLY GONE REPORTER-
LEGISLATURE TO. THE THING
AMOUNT OF POLITICAL DOCUMENT
WORKER WHO HAVE BEEN SHUT OUT
OF THE FROM THE FEDERAL HAVE
BEEN ACCOUNTED HAVE RECEIVED. A
QUICKLY EMERGING LEGISLATORS
COULD OF GATE AND MILLER
PREPAYMENT CALL I FIND-
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED. IN TO BE THE
PROCESS OF. NECESSARY RELIEF
UNDER UNDER CLEAR COMMUNITY I
IT'S- SHOULD BE EMBARRASSED.
ABOUT THE LACK THING YOU LIVE
OR- HI OF SUPPORT THAT A VERY
BY OF THE REPORT PRIVATELY
DOLLARS OR MORE A YEAR AGO.
EVERYTHING THAT WE ARE NOW.
ANOTHER SIX DOLLARS TO A VERY
LIMITED ON OF FOLKS I'M
THINKING ABOUT THE LOCAL WAY
OUR COMMUNITY DOES A LOT MORE.
THEY ARE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
YOU KNOW. THAT ARE FEEDING
THERE ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY.
WE'VE IDENTIFIED. WHAT THIRTY
BY YOU CAN THREAT. THAT DOES
ARE BAD UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
DURING THE PANDEMIC HAVE DIED
AFTER HE CLIMBED OVER. LAST
WORKERS YOU KNOW IF YOU CAN
WRAP A. SOCIAL WORKERS. I
SHOULD WORKERS THAT WE COLLECT
THEM THE WHITE THANK YOU ARE
YOU COULD WRAP UP A DEAL ON
DACA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
NOW TO LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AT MADAM CHAIR AND
THIS IS CHRIS. REP THE
MANUFACTURE HOUSING JUSTICE WE
REPRESENT MORE THAN HALF OF THE
MANUFACTURED HOUSING
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE. WHAT
WE DON'T HAVE AN OF FACIAL
POSITION ON EIGHTY EIGHTY OR SB
NINETY ONE YET- WE DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE BY THIS COMMITTEE AND
OTHERS IN THE ADMINISTRATION.
MANUFACTURED HOUSING REPRESENTS
SAFE SECURE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPTIONS FOR HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. OUR MEMBERS DURING
THE BUSINESS OF PROVIDING
HOUSING. WE DON'T WANT TO
AFFECT PEOPLE IT DOESN'T HELP A
RESIDENT IN AND DOESN'T HELP
THE OWNER. THAT'S WHY MANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE BEEN OR
WORKING WITH OUR RESIDENTS
AFFECTED BY COMMITTEE NINETEEN
TO STAY IN THEIR HOMES. THE
MAJORITY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES TO INVESTED
THEIR LIFE SAVINGS IN PROVIDING
HOUSING OPTIONS FOR FAMILIES
AND SENIORS. AND IT'S CRITICAL
THAT ANY LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION.
HELP INSURE PROPERTY OWNERS CAN
CONTINUE PROVIDING HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES TO NEARLY SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK AND- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN OUTLINE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY
NAME IS MARIA CRAP YEAH AND I'M
A STAFF ATTORNEY AT LEGAL AID
AT WORK A NONPROFIT THAT
PROVIDES FREE LEGAL EDUCATION
ADVICE. AND ADVOCACY FOR LOW
WAGE WORKERS ACROSS THE STATE
WE HEARD EARLIER AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE HEARING THAT
53% OF JOBLESS ARE FROM LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. AND ABOUT
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION WORKERS
ARE STILL UNEMPLOYED- I KNOW
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT HOUSING
BUT I THINK IT IS ESSENTIAL
THAT WE PRIORITIZE EMERGENCY
PAID SICK LEAVE. PROJECT
BECAUSE OF HOW IT AFFECTS BOTH
WORKERS SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC WE RECEIVED
THOUSANDS OF CALLS FROM WORKERS
IMPACTED BY CULMINATING WHEN
THEY'VE HAD ACCESS TO BASIC
DAYS THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO STAY
HOME AND STOP THE SPREAD WHEN
THEY HAVEN'T THEY BEEN FORCED
INTO AN IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE.
EITHER GO TO WORK AND RISK
RATING FOR THE NINETEENTH
BIRTHDAY HOME AND LOSE INCOME
AND ARE JOB SEEKERS OF THE
POSSIBLE CHOI THEY ARE LEFT
WITH NO OPTION BUT TO RETURN TO
WORK. IN THEIR AND THE PUBLIC'S
HELP IN CONTINUING TO SPREAD
CULMINATING I'M SURE THAT YOU
ALL WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED TO
HEAR THAT THE THING THAT CHOI
MARGARET THATCHER THE TO KEEP
WORKING TO TRY AND EARN INCOME.
ON JANUARY FIRST FEDERAL PAID
SICK DAYS AND BY EXTENSION THE
STATE SACRAMENTO. STATE AND IN
TURN MILLIONS OF WORKERS INTO
THE PREDICAMENT THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT THE TICKET HAD DEVISED
DURING A DEMOCRATS ONLY NEED
THE STATE TO ACT TO ENSURE THAT
WORKERS CAN COME BY WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH DIRECTIVES AND ABOUT THE
SPECTACLE BUT NINETEEN. MOST OF
BEING ABLE TO KEEP THEIR INCOME
AND. JOB THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE
SIXTY. PLEASE AHEAD. WHEN I
FOUND NUMBER IS THERE ARE THE
OTHER NUMBER DENTAL QUARTER BY
LOOKED OFF COLOUR IN MIDDLE OF
THE LEVEL THEY- INTO AN ON MAY
STAY GIVEN ENOUGH NOT GOING
DOESN'T UP THE A COUPLE THE
LOCAL DOUBLES. DANTE LOOK LEGAL
THE LEGAL WILL BE AT NO I'M
MORE UNDERSTOOD YOU LEFT FROM
BOTTOM IT IF YOU THINK I'M- IN
I'LL LOVE LAURA HOW MANY THAT
YOU KNOW THAT STATE AND LOCAL
YESTERDAY. I MEAN LOOK AT THE
END OF THE ON THE VEHICLE MANY
THOUGHT A BROKER TO BE BACK A
LOT EVEN IF IDEA I THE MONEY TO
DOES NOT THAT YOU NAUTICAL THAT
NOT ON IN A LOT IN THE BACK
OKAY GO WITH AND WEBER I'VE
BEEN YOU KNOW EVEN NEED A IN
THE END IN THE MAKE IT ON
CALIFORNIA I'M NOT. YEAH I'M
MORE AND WILL NOT LET THIS THIS
IS MY YOUR COLOR LOOK NOTHING
TO KILEY. IN MARCH OF COUNSEL.
FROM YOU HAVE TO THAT WHEN THEY
FAILED AFTER WANTED ECONOMY AND
BARELY GOT IT OUT ASSUMING
WE'RE NOT GONNA THE OTHER
DIDN'T STOP THERE THE END UP
ALSO READY THE YEAH BUT A
LITTLE MENTAL THAT MEANT THAT
THE MONEY THAT IS NOT GOING TO
I'M NOT. THE CALIFORNIA I'M
LOOKING TO COMMONSENSE IS THE-
OUR.
BUT OUR GOAL TRULY IS
KEEPING THE HOUSE THE STATE AS
WELL. I WOULD POINT OUT THAT IT
WILL BE DIFFICULT FOR MANY OF
OUR MEMBERS TO WAIT UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH FOR RENT THAT WAS
COMING DUE JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST- BUT OUR PARTY WITH
RENTAL ASSISTANCE MORE VERY
GRATEFUL THAT WAS INCLUDED. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING A THREE
MONTH PROGRAM. BUT NOT OVERLY
BURDENSOME AND TO LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
HOUSING AGENCY AND DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
AND NOW TO LINE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PRODUCT
MARKETING H. CALIFORNIA LEADING
H. CALIFORNIA STATE LEADING
ADVOCATE FOR QUALITY NOT IN
YOUR LIVING IN CARE WE APPLAUD
THE ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATURE EXTENSION OF THE
FICTION MORATORIUM AND RENTAL
RELIEF PROGRAM THANK YOU FOR
YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS
COMPLICATED AND TIME SENSITIVE
LEGISLATION. LEADING A STRONG
BELIEF AND OF EXPLORATORIUM THE
ULTIMATELY EFFECTIVE IF IT IS
ACCOMPANIED WITH HER ABOUT
RENTAL ASSISTANCE THE TWO POINT
SIX BILLION FEDERAL DOLLARS
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO BRIDGE
THE GAP BTWEEN RENT AND RENT
PAID TO THE LNDMARK. HOWEVER
WE DON'T THINK THAT IS ENOUGH
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF LANDLORDS
TO KEEP THEIR TENANT SAFELY HOW
TO. DECIDE ON THE MOST RECENT
ROUND OF FEDERAL PANDEMIC
RENTAL ASSISTANCE THAT MANY
CALIFORNIA CITIES RAN OUT OF
FUNDS IN A MATTER OF DAYS WE
ASK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION AUGMENT THIS
CRITICAL PROGRAM- THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU KNOW
TO LINE. FORTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MERIAL
BLOCK AND IMPROPER TURNING WITH
THE NATIONAL HOUSING LAW
PROJECT WE ARE FEDERAL POLICY
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION ADVANCING
HOUSING RIGHT WELCOME TIENEN.
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY RECORD
NEEDED A NATIONAL EMERGENCY
RENTAL ASSISTANCE WORKING
GROUP. FOCUSED ON STATE AND
LOCAL IMPLEMENTATION OF FEDERAL
FUNDING. WE WOULD SUGGEST
SEVERAL IMPROVEMENTS TO- KATHY
NINETY ONE FRENCH OPEN
PROVISION. ADMINISTERING RENTAL
PROVISION PROGRAMS THAT THE
SCALE IS AN INCREDIBLY COMPLEX
PROCESS AND IT WILL REQUIRE
CHANGES AND ADJUSTMENTS AND
PROGRAMS BEGAN IMPLEMENTATION-
AT THE NINETY ONE SHOULD
BUILDING BROADER COLLECTIBILITY
FOR THE PROGRAM ADJUSTMENTS FOR
EXAMPLE- IF THERE'S A LITTLE
RATE OF WINDWARD PARTICIPATION
OR RACIALLY INEQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF CRIME. TRENDING
IN AB SHOULD ALL HAVE A FORMAL
WAY PROVIDE INTO THESE
NECESSARY CHANGES- IN ADDITION
THE 25% DROP CAME INTO TIENEN
MUST BE PAIRED WITH
CORRESPONDING BRENT FORGIVENESS
PROVISION. TO THE 80% PAYMENTS
TO LANDLORDS- WITHOUT THE
TENANTS WILL STILL FACE
DEVASTATING LONG TERM ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES AND POTENTIAL
ADDICTION- FLOPPY THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE- DECLARATION
REQUIREMENT- THAT'S BEEN ADDED
TO THE UNLAWFUL DETAINER
PROCESS HOW THE STRENGTHENING
CLARIFIED- A LANDLORD'S FAILURE
TO APPLY FOR. ORG RENTAL SYSTEM
MUST BE A COMPLETE DIFFERENT TO
NON PAYMENT OF ACTION AND IT
MUST BE THE LANDLORD BURDEN TO
PROVE THAT THEY CAN NOT ATTAIN
RENTAL AND- YOU'LL FOLLOW THE
DIVISIONAL BRITAIN COMMENTS
WITH BROTHER. THANK. YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND NOW. TO LINE.
TWENTY HELLO THE NUMBERS-
MEANING IT'S WITHIN YOUR BUDGET
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
WAREHOUSE WORKERS REPLACEMENT I
DO STRONGLY URGE YOU TO GIVE IT
A LONG ABILITY TO UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS THAT THEY SET OUT OF
THE MOVIE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THREE INDEPENDENT
MAKE ALMOST A YEAR AND IT'S AN
UNDENIABLY. HARTFORD WHAT THE
FAMILIES. THANK YOUNG GAVE
ARCHITECT. MILLION THAT TO CALL
TWO MILLION FIFTY BUCKS FROM
THE- I BUT EVEN NOW. A MIX BY
FAMILY WORK. A ONE TIME CAME OF
FIVE DOLLARS TO TALKING
COMMUNITY. IT IS NOT ENOUGH.
THANK HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT WE
THE BATTLE MEMBERS NOT OF
SHOULD BE HI TO WORRY ABOUT
LOSING THEIR- YOU. YOU CAN DENY
THAT. OVER NINETY HAD HAD ON
OUR CALIFORNIA. RIGHT MANY
CONSIDER- HEAD OF HOUSE RIGHT
ABOUT BRED BY HAD BECOME ILL OR
HAVE HAVE TO WAIT DUE TO COLD.
MARKETS FAMILY LEARNING OR YOU
CAN HELP. JEOPARDY OF HUNGER
ADDS UP APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS YOU KNOW YOU'RE
ALREADY LOGGED INTO BILL'S.
RIGHT NOW THE MINUTE CALIFORNIA
I DON'T EQUITABLE RELIEF NOW
STARTING WITH INCREASES LISTING.
IF I STILL EIGHT HUNDRED THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU I
PLEASE CALL WE ARE SPEAKING TO.
THE BILLS BEFORE WHICH ARE THE
VICKS MORE TO IN THE ASSISTANCE.
BY YOUR KERN ABOUT OTHER ISSUE.
AND SIR YOU MAY THOSE TO THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE OR SPEAK AT
OUR FUTURE HEARING WHEN WE DEAL
WITH THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS
BUT RIGHT NOW. WE ARE DEALING
WITH TWO BILLS AND THEY ARE THE
ARE TO DEAL THEY ARE SUBJECT
MATTER THE EVICTION. MORATORIUM
AND. THE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NOW
TRY TWENTY PLEASE HEAD. HELLO
THIS IS KATE WATER WITH A
WORKING FAMILY COALITION I
WANNA MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF
YOU SEE W. AND LEGAL AID AT
WORK AND WE ARE ALSO CALLING ON
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE TO
IMMEDIATELY ENACT EMERGENCY
PAID SICK DAYS WITH OUR
MILITARY FOR OTHERS ARE NOT CUT
YOU OFF THE MAIN THE MAIN
DURING THEIR HOLIDAY RETURNING
JOB CUTTING THIS OFF THIS IS
NOT. ABOUT BILLS BEFORE US
THANK YOU. NOW SPEAK PLEASE.
THANK YOU IN THAT IT COMES FROM
LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS GENERAL
KNOWLEDGE WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY TO OFFER OUR
SUPPORT OF AB AT WITH CONCERN.
WESTERN CENTER BELIEVE IT IS
IMPORTANT TO PASS AN EXTENSION
OF THE EVICTION MORATORIUM AND
WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT EBT
ELIMINATE RENTAL THAT FOR SOME
TENANTS. BUT WE URGE THE
LEGISLATOR TO EXPAND THIS
QUALITY TO ALL TENANTS.
INCLUDING IF NECESSARY BY USING
PARTS OF OUR SURPLUS GENERAL
FUND. DRAFTED THE BILL NEEDS
TENANTS AT THE MARK OF THE
LANDLORD EMPLOYERS AND
COLLECTORS AND THE POWER
IMBALANCE IS ONE OF THE
GREATEST PROBLEMS WITH THIS
BILL. WE HAVE TIME TO FIX IT
BUT WE MUST BE DONE PROMPTLY.
LASTLY WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE FAILURE TO INCLUDE
VOICES THE TENANT AND THE LACK
OF HEARING. TO FINE TUNE THIS
BILL BECAUSE WE KNOW. THAT THIS
WILL HAVE TO BE DEALT WITH
AGAIN IN JUNE IT IS ESSENTIAL
THAT THE LEGISLATOR INVOLVED
TENANTS. IN CRAFTING THE NEXT
VERSION OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND NOW TO LINE
FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN FIVE
ZERO. HI THIS IS ARSENIO MOLINA
WITH MI FAMILIA VOTA WE'RE
LOOKING OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
ORGANIZATION FOUNDED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT TO
COMMENT THAT FEDERAL EMERGENCY
PICKS PAID SICK DAYS. EXPIRED
ON JANUARY FIRST LEAVING
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA WORKERS
WITHOUT MERGES YOU PAID SICK
DAYS. WE NEED YOU TO ENACT
EMERGENCY PAID SICK DAYS NOW
BECAUSE WE KNOW TO RESULT. IN
MORE PEOPLE STAYING HOME WHEN
THEY ARE SICK AND- LOWER THE IN
TEXAS RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NOT A LINE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS RENEE
SO SEVERAL AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE GREAT MONDAY
LABOR CENTER AND ALL MONTH OUR
WOMEN'S ORGANIZATION. WE
PROVIDE SERVICES TO AND HELP IN
POWER THE LABOR DOMESTIC
WORKERS AND FARM WORKERS IN
CINEMA COUNTY. WE SUPPORT GRANT
FORGIVENESS FOR ALL TENANTS
PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME CAN. WE
START WE ALSO STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO GIVE THE SAME AMOUNT OF
RELIEF TO UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
WHO HAVE BEEN SHUT OUT OF
RELIEF FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AS THEIR
COUNTERPARTS HAVE RECEIVED AND
SPECIFICALLY WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE THE
GOLDEN GATE STIMULUS PAYMENT I
CAN FILERS. TWO ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS IN ORDER
TO BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
PROVIDING NECESSARY MARKET
EFFECT THAT UNDERSERVED AND I'M
RECOGNIZE COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
MODERATOR YOU AN OUTLINE. FIFTY
TWO. OUR HAN WITH WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS USA IN SAN JOSE
STANDING IN THE KITCHEN
MORATORIUM AND PROTECTING
RENTERS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
FOR AFTER TEN DIRECT. IN
ADDITION UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
ARE SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
AND MAY STILL BE VULNERABLE
EVEN UNDER ANY STATE
LEGISLATION WHICH IS WHY IT IS
SO IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES INCLUDING
INCREASING THE GOLDEN GATE AND
MILLER I CAN'T FIND WORDS.
FINALLY EXPAND EMERGENCY
BASICALLY ACROSS CALIFORNIA SO
THAT PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO GO TO
WORK IN THE ACTUALLY ARE ABLE
TO GET THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC
CAME OUT THE OTHER. SIDE THANK
YOU. MODERATOR HOW MAY MORE TO
WE HAVE. WE HAVE FOUR MORE
GREAT AND COLORS I REALLY DO I
KNOW THAT YOU ALL CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT THE OTHER ISSUES YOU'RE
BRINGING. BUT I HOPE THAT YOU
CAN KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO THE
BILLS BEFORE US AND AS I
INDICATED WE WILL HAVE A BUDGET
HEARING ON THOSE OTHER ISSUES
AND ADDITIONALLY WE WELCOME YOU
SENDING US YOUR COMMENTS IN
WRITING. MODERATOR PROCEED.
THANK YOU AN OUTLINE FORTY NINE.
STE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN I THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME MY NAME IS GERRY INSURER I'M
A PROFESSOR IN THE SOLE PRICE
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC POLICY AND I
DIRECT THE PRICING FOR SOCIAL
INNOVATION IN THE HOMELESSNESS
QUALITY RESEARCH INSTITUTE I
WAS SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP IN PROVIDING
STABILITY FOR RENTERS- AS WE
KNOW WALL INITIAL CARES ACT
OPPONENTS PROVIDED SUPPORT FOR
MANY HOUSEHOLDS AND PEOPLE WERE
ABLE TO STAY CURRENT ON THE
RENT RECENT DATA SUGGESTS THAT
ONE IN FIVE RENTER HOUSEHOLDS
ARE BEHIND. THE BUILDING
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT SUFFICIENT TO
DEAL WITH THIS AGREEMENT THE
LIABILITY- TARGETING ASSISTANCE
TO THOSE WHO NEED IT MOST IS
BOTH STRAIGHTFORWARD AND
DIFFICULT DISTRICT COURT IN THE
SENSE THAT WE CAN TARGET
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND HOUSEHOLDS BUT
IT'S ALSO DIFFICULT BECAUSE
IT'S HARD TO SAY WHETHER A
PARTICULAR HOUSEHOLD MIGHT BE
MOST AT RISK OF BEING AFFECTED
OR FALLING INTO HOMELESSNESS-
IN PARTICULAR IF THIS BILL
COULD TARGET COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN SERVED WELL BY.
OTHER SAFETY NET PROGRAMS LIKE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY MAKE STATUS
COMMUNITY NOT BEING A HUNDRED
HOUSEHOLDS EXPECT TRACK THEN
YOU'RE GOING TO BE IN A BETTER
POSITION- THE NEXT STEP EITHER
WITH THE SPELL OF THE NEXT
WOULD BE TO THINK ABOUT A
LONGER ERM STRATEGY FOR THOSE
WHO ARE UNABLE TO RECEIVE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE FROM THIS
PROGRAM WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT
HOW WE CAN FINANCE THE RENTAL
LIABILITY WITH FEDERAL OR STATE
RESOURCES. TO PROVIDE CLARITY
IN IT WHAT THEY CAN EXPECT THE
PAID WHEN IT WILL BE OWED
THIRTY THE LANDMARKS AND
LOOKING BETTER SO THEY CAN
AVOID MORTGAGE FORECLOSURE IN
CREDIT MARKETS MARKET
DISRUPTION. SO THEY CAN PLAN OR
IF YOUR COULD YOU EVER THANK
YOU FOR. ME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NOW TO LINE FORTY. I'D
PATRICK WELCH WITH CALIFORNIA
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING PUBLICLY ON
ELECTRIC UTILITY PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES HAVE A OFFICIAL
POSITION ON AB EIGHTY BUT WE
WANT TO EXPRESS APPRECIATION
THAT BOTH THAT THE FEDERAL BILL
AND THAT AB AT IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR ARE
RECOGNIZING THAT MONIES CAN BE
PUT FORWARD FOR RENTERS AND
LANDLORDS TO ACCESS THOSE FUNDS
TO PAY DOWN UTILITY DEBT
THROUGH THEIR LANDLORDS. WE
THINK THIS IS A POSITIVE START
TO ADDRESSING THE ISSUE HOWEVER
WE WOULD NOTE THAT- USE PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES THEIR CUSTOMERS
STARTED SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
UTILITY THAT THAT WE ANTICIPATE
WILL NOT BE FULLY DRESSED BY
THIS INITIAL FUNDING WE THINK
THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE IN
THIS AREA INCLUDING ASSISTANCE
FOR OTHER TYPES OF CUSTOMERS
LIKE HOMEOWNERS. COMMERCIAL
CUSTOMERS AND DIRECT ASSISTANCE
FOR UTILITIES TO HELP ADDRESS A
RESURGENCE RESULTING FROM COLD
AT NINETEEN PUBLIC ELECTRIC
UTILITIES AND WATER AGENCIES
ARE NOT FOR PROFIT OWNED BY OUR
CUSTOMERS AND THE RATES ARE
BASED ON COST SERVICE. MEMBERS
ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
OUR CUSTOMERS TO ADDRESS
BILLING ISSUES AND ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO COMMUTING TO WORK
WITH YOUAND THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION FURTHER ON THIS
ISSUE IN THE MONTHS TO COME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK AND WE HAVE MORE PEOPLE
COMING AND- OUTLINED. THREE
THANK YOU MARTI AMADO FAMILY
MEMBER CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SENIOR COMMUNITY ACTION NETWORK
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU. THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
FOR PUTTING THIS FORWARD AB-
SEVEN NINE EIGHTY ALLOWS NOT
PERFECT THEY WILL PROVIDE A LOT
OF HELP THE TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES TO
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS SENIORS AND- THE DIRECT
SUPPORT WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND THAT WE WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
ADMINISTRATION THE COMING
MONTHS FOR YOU KNOW MAYBE A
LONGER TERM SOLUTION- AT THE
BUDGET PROCESS MOVES FOR BUT
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THIS UP. AND FOR ALL
YOU'RE DOING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NOW TO LINE FIFTY SIX.
THIS. NINE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DAISY AND I'M CALLING
IN ON BEHALF OF THE WAREHOUSE
WORKER RESEARCH CENTER AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE RANK
MORATORIUM AND THE EXTENSION OF
PAID SICK LEAVE- I THINK
THERE'S ALSO RELATE TO WHO
WOULD HAVE BEEN MOST AFFECTED
BY A COLD WIND AND SUN STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO- THE SAME AMOUNT OF
RELIEFTO UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
WHO HAVE BEEN SHUT OUT OF
NEARLY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS THEIR
COUNTERPARTS HAVE A SEAT THE IS
A CLEAR URGE LEGISLATOR TO
INCREASE THE GOLDEN GATE THE
NEW AND PAYMENT I CAN FILERS.
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED IN ORDER TO
BEGIN THE COMING YOU HOME I
DIDN'T NOTHING. REALLY THE- A
THANK YOU AND NOW TO LINE. FOR
SIXTY ONE. WELL I'M SIXTY ONE
DISCONNECTED NOW TO LINE THE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FAVOR OF THE FEDERAL EMERGENCY
PAID SICK DAYS AND RENTAL
MORATORIUM THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY PAID SICK DAYS THAT
YOU KNOW EXPIRED ON JANUARY
FIRST AND I DON'T KNOW I ONLY
INTO MY OWN WORKERS. WE DON'T
WANT OTHER CAMPING RETESTING
MONEY RIGHT NOW ON THE FEDERAL
PAID SICK LEAVE THANK YOU.
PARDON WE ARE NOT TAKING
TESTIMONY RIGHT NOW ON THE
FEDERAL PAID SICK LEAVE. YOU
MAY SUBMITTED TO US OR NOT
UNTIL WE HAVE THE STIMULUS-
HEARING THIS IS ON FICTION
MORATORIUM AND RENTER
PROTECTIONS. OKAY WELL I'M IN
FAVOR OF- RENTAL MORE. GREAT
THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT. SURE
THANK YOU AND OUTLINED SIXTY
TWO. PRICES ARE NAY GROWING
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES- BEHALF OF CITY LEADERS
AND CALIFORNIANS BORN EIGHTY
TWO CITY SECTORS TRACKED ACROSS
OUR APPRECIATION FOR THE
PROTECTION PROVIDE DIRECTIONS-
AND INDIRECTLY IS WHAT THE
LANDLORD- OUR CITY LEADERS ARE
PRIORITIZING- THE CASHIER ARE
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE THAT
ALL RESIDENTS IN ALL CITIES
RECEIVE THE AID THEY NEED. ARE
EQUITABLE BASIS AND TELL A LOT
OF WORK TO BE DONE WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK BEING DONE
TO GET US TO THIS PLACE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD. TO BE AT THE
TABLE WITH YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN OUTLINE
SIXTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING YOU'RE
NOT TAKING THE MONEY AND
BASICALLY RIGHT NOW IS THAT
RIGHT. STATE OR FEDERAL WE ARE
TAKING TESTIMONY RIGHT NOW ON
THE BILLS ON THE VIXEN
MORATORIUM AND THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND THAT IS ALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND OUR FINAL COMMENT COMES TO
MIND SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I KNOW A LOT FOR YOUR
WORK ON A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
MY NAME IS LENNY FACTORY AND
I'M HERE SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE TECHNICAL CLIENTS NOT
AFFECTING THE WHOLE ECONOMY I'M
HERE IN BOTH THE PART OF THE
EXTENSION OF THE INFECTION MARK
TWAIN AND REGULARLY WALK THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND SOMEONE IS
JUST GIVING UP NOW ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. AND NOW TO LINE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MANY
VETS HAVE YET ANOTHER TIME THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INLAND COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE IMMIGRANT RIGHT
COALITION IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
WE WORK WITH THE RICHEST
UNIFICATION I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF. IN THE MARK TWAIN-
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT- EXPECTS
KNOWING THAT. LOW INCOME
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY IT WE ARE IN. THE
MARKET. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. EXCELLENT
BOND. THROUGH ALL THIS CHATTER
IN THE BACK ANYWAY SO- AFTER.
WE HAVE NOW HEARD FROM THE
PUBLIC. I HAVE A- COMMON I WANT
TO MAKE AND THEN I WANT TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OF A- MEMBERS
THAT HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
BEFORE I TAKE A MOTION SENATOR
NEWMAN. AND SENATOR BRADFORD
AND THEN I THINK SENATOR WILL
OKAY LET ME JUST WRITE THAT
DOWN- ALL RIGHT SO ON. FIVE I
WANTED TO RAISE ONE ISSUE THAT
I THINK IS WORTH CONSIDERING IT
ISN'T SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE TO
ALTER IN TERMS OF OUR ADOPTION
OF THE BILL TODAY BUT I THOUGHT
SENATOR CORTESE'S OF A QUESTION
OR SUGGESTION WOULD BE TO GET
EITHER WAY ABOUT A CALL CENTER
HAD SOME MERIT AND I NOTE THAT
THE UNTIL ANALYSIS SHOWS THAT
THERE IS THE EXPECTATION THAT
THERE WOULD BE. A WEBSITE THAT
WAS AVAILABLE FOR THE
APPLICATIONS- YOU KNOW TWENTY
FOUR HOURS SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
AND OF COURSE- YOU KNOW ANYTIME
YOU SET UP A NEW SYSTEM LIKE
THAT THEY KEEP AND- WE'VE SEEN
IT BEFORE THEY CAN RUN INTO
PROBLEMS SO. OF COURSE- WE MAY
EXPERIENCE SOME OF THAT. AND
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT INTERNET ACCESS IS
STILL A CHALLENGE FOR SOME OF
THE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT MOST NEED
THIS ASSISTANCE. AND
ADDITIONALLY- AS WE PUT THE
WORD OUT. YOU MAY NOT ALWAYS
KNOW EXACTLY WHERE TO GO AND
SUCH AND SO TO IT I THINK IT
IS. WORTHWHILE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION IN. ROLLING THIS
OUT INDIAN- THERE ARE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE VENDOR.
WHETHER SOMETHING LIKE THAT OR
WHETHER SEPARATE VENDOR MIGHT
OPERATE A- CALL SYSTEM A CALL
CENTER. TO MAKE SURE THAT THE-
ASSISTANCE THE QUESTIONS ARE
BEING ANSWERED AND THOSE FOLKS
WHETHER LANDLORDS OR TENANTS.
KNOW EXACTLY HOW TO APPLY SINCE
OUR THINK ALL OF OUR OBJECTIVE
IS TO HAVE THIS WORK AS
OPTIMALLY AS POSSIBLE SO I JUST
WANT TO PUT THAT IN. TO THE
CONSIDERATION HACK- I DON'T
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT-
CHANGES HOW WE WOULD PROCEED ON
IS SOMETHING THAT COULD STILL
BE DONE. ALRIGHT WITH THAT LET
ME ASK AS SENATOR NEWMAN THEN
BRADFORD THAN WILK THEN
NIELSEN. AND THANK YOU CHAIR SO
I BE VOTE FOR THE TODAY I WANT
TO REVISIT ONE ISSUE THAT I
RAISED. AROUND THE LANGUAGE. OF
A REGARDING THE COMPENSATION
LEVEL- AND AS A RESULT NOW IT
READS IN FIVE OH EIGHT NINE
SEVEN. ASSISTANCE FOR RENTAL
ARREARS SHALL BE LIMITED TO
COMPENSATION OF 80% OF AN
ELIGIBLE HOUSES ON TAPE RENTAL
DEBT. THAT IS LESS THAN CLEAR.
THAT COULD BE READ VERY EASILY
AS LIMITED TO MEETING UP TO BUT
NOT NECESSARILY TO. AND SO WHAT
I WOULD URGE YOU TO A TECHNICAL
FIX TO THAT LANGUAGE. THAT
WHICH I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT IS
NOT INCIDENTAL SHOWED THE
ASSURANCE. THAT WE GIVE
LANDLORDS THE AS TO THE AMOUNT
PROVIDED TO THEM. THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT COMPONENT IN THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO PARTICIPATE.
YEAH AND SO WITH THAT I GOT
ASKED THAT WE CONSIDER MAKING
THAT TECHNICAL CHANGE FOR
CLARITY SAKE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR NEWMAN CENTER
BRADFORD. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I WANT TO THANK
PROTEOME AS WELL AS SHOW FOR
ALONG ME TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS
HEARING TODAY AS ONE OF THE
LEAD AUTHORS LARGE YEAR OF- AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT MATTER MEASURE.
IT'S NO DOUBT WE ALL HAVE
CONSTITUENTS WITH PROGRAMMING
TO PAY THEIR RENT DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY DUE TO COLD BUT
NINETEEN. AND THIS CRISIS IS
HIT THE LESS FORTUNATE-
DISPROPORTIONATELY UNEMPLOYMENT
IS FIVE TIMES HIGHER AMONG LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. WHICH ARE
MORE LIKELY TO BE RENTERS AND I
THINK WERE ALL HOW THE PRIORITY
OF KEEPING FOLKS HOUSED THERE'S
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT HOWEVER WE
ALSO HAVE CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE
SMALL LANDLORDS AND THEY'RE
HURTING AS WELL. STRUGGLING TO
PAY THEIR MORTGAGES AND I'M NOT
REFERRING TO THE LARGE
CORPORATE ENTITIES THAT EXIST
AGAIN I'M TALKING ABOUT THE MOM
AND POP OPERATORS WHO USE THEIR
PROPERTY FOR RETIREMENT OR THE
PAY THEIR COLLEGE- THE KIDS.
COLLEGE FINE OR OR WHAT HAVE
YOU. THE PRIME EXAMPLE
YESTERDAY WHEN I WAS EUROPE- TO
BOARD MY PLANE AND WAS FIVE L.
A. X. OFFICERS HUDDLED UP
TALKING AND ONE OF THEM
RECOGNIZE ME BECAUSE I DID A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. A NUMBER
OF YEARS AGO THAT CHANGE YOUR
RETIREMENT AND THEY CAME OVER
TO TALK TO ME ABOUT IT IN THAT
CONVERSATION THEY MENTION THAT.
OVER LANDLORDS. AND THEY'RE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE HEIR
MORTGAGE AND THE LAST THING
THEY WANTED TO DO. IS THE
VICTIM ANY OF THEIR TENANTS
MANY WHO HAVE BEEN THERE FOR A
LONG TIME BUT WHEN SOME DID
IT FROM A LOT OF MY
CONSTITUENTS THAT- THEY
APPRECIATE TO TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. BUT SOME OTHER TENANTS
ARE JUST STARTING OUT AND NOT
MAKING ANY GOOD FAITH EFFORT TO
MAKE THE 25% AND ALLOW IT TO.
FOLLOW UP IN ARREARS AND AT THE
SAME TIME THEY'RE GOING OUT
BUYING NEW CARS AND OTHER.
ITEMS THAT THEY SEE ON A
REGULAR BASIS SO I JUST WISH WE
COULD KIND OF LIKE. A LITTLE
MORE TEETH AND MAKING SURE THAT
A FOOT. TENET IS ABLE TO PAY
THE 25% THEY DO SO WITHOUT LED
IT ACCRUE AS MANY OF THEM SAY
IT'S HAPPENING. THERE'S ALSO- A
LONG HISTORY OF PEOPLE OF COLOR
USING RENTAL PROPERTIES AS
INVESTMENTS. AFTER BEING DENIED
OR DISCOURAGE FROM OTHER TYPES
OF- INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND THIS
AGREEMENT BECAUSE THIS
RECOGNIZES THE NEED FOR.
TENANTS AS WELL AS LANDLORDS TO
BE COVERED. IT IS NOT AN END
ALL BE ALL LIKE YOU SAY IT'S
NOT THE PERFECT WORLD BUT IT
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY IN ORDER
TO MOVE FORWARD. YOU ARE USING
JUST- ALLELES INVESTMENT A RANT
GET. THAT FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
IS STILL A HEAVY BURDEN THAT
LANDLORDS ARE CARING TO HELP
THE STATE OUT AT THIS CRITICAL
TIME SPECIFICALLY SMALL
LANDLORDS DESERVE THIS RELIEF.
THAT'S WHY TODAY'S ACTIONS IS
SO IMPORTANT. THE NEW RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED RENT
ARREARS AMONG THE MOST
VULNERABLE. AND THE 20% CUT
THERE WERE ASKING SMALL.
LANDLORDS TO TAKE IS NECESSARY
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES BUT
THIS IS STILL DESERVES
ATTENTION FOR MANY GOOD ACTORS
AMONG THOSE LANDLORDS SO THERE
ARE TWO THINGS THAT I'M ASKING
ON AS WE MOVE FORWARD OF THE
ADMINISTRATION TO WORK WITH
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
EXISTING TALKS TO DIFFERENT
LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO GET THE
WORD OUT INCLUDING WORKING WITH
TRUSTED. LOCAL VOICES FROM MY
COLLEAGUES OF OUR EXPRESSED-
WE'RE GOING TO GET THIS
INFORMATION OUT TO THE
COMMUNITIES AND REPORT BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON WHETHER
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT MAY BE
NEEDED FOR RENTERS AND LOWER
LOWER LANDLORDS NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR THE PRORAM PARTICULARLY
THOSE IN HIGH COST AREAS WHO
EXCEED. THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME
REQUIREMENTS BUT ARE STILL
STRUGGLING TO FILL ON THAT NOTE
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
AND I THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD. SENATOR WILK. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
CONGRATULATIONS ON THIS NEW
POSITION I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO
DO VERY WELL SO ANYWAY I WANT
TO DO- IMPARTS IN INFORMATION
AND THEN MAKE A STATEMENT AND
THEN I HAD A QUESTION. BUT I
DON'T THINK DEPARTMENT FINANCES
HERE ANYMORE SO JUST THROW IT
OUT AND SOMEBODY CAN GET BACK
TO ME LATER- WHILE THEY WERE
TALKING AND I WENT. ON A SEARCH
ENGINE AND I DISCOVERED THAT
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF STATE HOUSING
AGENCIES. FOR CALIFORNIA
RENTERS ARE ARE IN ARREARS
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION TO FIVE POINT SIX
BILLION. SO CLEARLY THIS IS
JUST A DOWN PAYMENT THIS IS
CERTAINLY NOT A PANACEA TO OUR
CHALLENGES. AND THEN WE HAD THE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE HAD ONE THE
ASSOCIATIONS FOR WATER AGENCIES
TALK ABOUT. THEIR STRUGGLES IN
AGAIN- WENT ON AND SEARCHED THE
INTERNET AND IN CALIFORNIA IT
APPEARS THAT- AT THE RATE
PAYERS- ONE POINT SIX BILLION
TO CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
WITH A BILLION OF THAT BEING IN
THE ACTUAL COST OF WATER. BOND
BUT ON THIS BILL SO- WE GOT TWO
BILLS TODAY I'M GOING TO VOTE
YES ON AB SEVENTY NINE ON AB
ADR I'M GONNA STAINED. TODAY I
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION I
JUST LITERALLY GOT THIS AN HOUR
BEFORE. WE WENT INTO THE
SESSION I UNDERSTAND WE GOT
AROUND THIS BY AL THE MEMBERS
OF THE- I'M TALK. WITH THAT SO
TO ME THIS BILL FRAMES THE
LANDLORDS TO ACTUALLY HAVING A
CHOICE BETWEEN WHETHER TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. BUT I GOT
YOU GOT ASK YOURSELF IS IT
REALLY CHOICE BECAUSE EITHER
WAY. THE FORCE TO FORGIVE A
SUBSTANTIAL PORTION OF THE RENT
OWED THEY CAN EITHER
PARTICIPATE IN THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. AND GET A
MAXIMUM 80% OF THE RENTAL
ARREARS AND HAVE TO FORGIVE THE
REST. OR THEY CAN CHOOSE NOT TO
PARTICIPATE. IN WHICH CASE YOU
GET ONLY 25% ARE STILL
EFFECTIVELY FORCED TO FORGET AT
LEAST SOME PORTION OF THE REST-
BECAUSE THEY ARE BARRED FROM
RECOVERING DAMAGES IN COURT.
WHEN THEY DIDN'T COOPERATE IN
SEEKING RENTAL ASSISTANCE SO. I
KNOW IT'S A CHALLENGE- I DIED I
DON'T THINK THEY REALLY HAVE A
CHOICE IN THE END IF WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD I THINK
YOU NEED TO BE FULLY FUNDED.
AND THEN THE FINAL THING- AND I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE HERE ANYMORE. BUT AFTER
TODAY'S DEVASTATING AUDIT FROM
THE STATE AUDITOR. AS IT
RELATES. TO A FRAUD IN E. D. D.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S A WAY. THAT THIS RENTAL
RATE RELIEF PAYMENT GOES ONLY
TO LANDLORDS. WHO HAVE DECLARED
RENTAL INCOME WHEN THEY FILE
THEIR TAX DOCUMENTS SO WE CAN
AVOID THE TYPE OF FRAUD THAT
WE'VE SEEN A- DVD. SO WITH
THAT- I WANT TO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AGAIN ON THE D. AND I ON
ON AB SEVENTY NINE AND AS OF
TODAY I'M GOING TO BE A
STANDING ON EIGHTY. UNTIL I
HAVE MORE INFORMATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR WORLD-
SENATOR NIELSEN. YES SENATOR
KABIR MADAM CHAIR I ALSO FIND
THIS MERITORIOUS AND WORTHY OF
SUPPORT- BUT WITH THE QUESTION.
THE ROLL OUT OF THESE MATTERS
HILDA FOR HAS LARGELY BEEN
CLUMSY. THE FIRST OF THIS WEEK
ANNOUNCEMENT WAS MADE ABOUT EX
EXPEDITING THE VACCINE.
DISSEMINATION AND IT WAS WHAT
PUT PICKED MY INTEREST WAS YOUR
MENTION OF A WEBSITE APPLICABLE
TO THIS AREA. IT WEBSITE WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER IN THE WEEK
APPLICABLE TO THE VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION. HOWEVER AFTER ITS
ANNOUNCEMENT THEN I FOUND OUT
FROM OTHER SOURCES. THE ONLY
ONE COUNTY WAS GOING TO BE
ACCESSING THAT WEBSITE THE
MEDIA ONLY ONE COUNT OF FIFTY
EIGHT. AND THE OTHER FIFTY
EIGHT LIKELY WOULD TAKE UP TO
SIX WEEKS. TO HAVE THAT AVAILED
OF THEM. MY POINT IS A LOT OF
THINGS THAT ARE GOING ON HERE
IN THIS EMERGENCY SITUATION AND
NO MATTER WHAT IT IS. THEY'RE
CONSTANTLY DONE INDOOR CHANGED
IN THE CITIZENS OF THAT WE
REPRESENT ARE AT BEST CONFUSED.
I THINK THAT MORE PLANNING HAS
TO GO IN TO THE CRAFTING OF
THIS LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS
THESE EMERGENCY SITUATIONS IT'S
QUITE CLEAR THAT THIS ONE
AGAIN. HAS BEEN NOT FULLY
COOKED IN THAT WE DIDN'T EVEN
GET IT UNTIL YESTERDAY SO WE
NEED TO SLOW DOWN THE TRAIN AND
BE MORE. CLEAR MORE DEFINITIVE
AND DISSEMINATED MORE WIDELY
AND MAKE IT ACCESSIBLE IF
THAT'S WHAT'S PROMISED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR CAFIERO
THEN SENATOR DRAWS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY SAY A FEW WORDS-
CENTERS I'M GONNA I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT IT BECAUSE- THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF US SENATOR
BRADFORD AND MYSELF ON THE
SENATE SIDE. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IT
BEEN REALLY WORKING VERY VERY
HARD ON THIS SINCE WE PASSED SB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT. IN AUGUST
LOOKING AT OUR CRYSTAL BALL
THINKING THAT IF WE GOT
OURSELVES TO JANUARY WE'D BE
OKAY. AND THE REALITY THE
SITUATION IS NONE OF US THOUGHT.
A YEAR LATER WE'D STILL BE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS PANDEMIC
WEARING MASKS AND WORRYING
ABOUT WHETHER WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GET A VACCINE OR NOT
WITHIN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
AND THERE WERE. A NUMBER OF
GOALS THAT WE WERE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH. ONE WISH TO PROVIDE
AN EXTENSION OF THE MORATORIUM
WHICH ENDS ON THE THIRTY FIRST
OF JANUARY. AND FURTHER TO THAT
END TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
WEREN'T THAT WE WERE PROTECTING
PEOPLE FROM ENDING UP HOMELESS
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC TO
PROVIDE RENTAL ASSISTANCE TO
LANDLORDS. WHO ARE. IN ARREARS
WITH OUR MORTGAGE PAYMENTS OR
HAVEN'T SEEN. THE MONEY THAT
THEY NEED FOR THEIR OWN
RETIREMENT. AND AND SO THERE
ARE MANY OF THEM ARE AT RISK OF
FORECLOSURE. AND THREE WE
WANTED TO PROVIDE HELP TO
TENANTS WHO ARE DROWNING IN
DEBT. IF THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PAY THEIR 25% THEY STILL OWE
75% OF THE RENT AND I HAD A
LEGAL AID OFFICE TELL ME. THAT
THIS DEBT WOULD FOLLOW THEM FOR
A GENERATION THAT'S THE THAT'S
THE SCOPE OF THIS PARTICULAR
DEBT. ON THE POOREST. IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO WORK FROM HOME AT
NIGHT I THANK GOD THAT I'M IN.
THE POSITION OF BEING ABLE TO
DO THIS WORK AT HOME AND HAVE
BEEN DOING IT AND I GET PAID
BUT NOT EVERYBODY HAS THAT
LUXURY. AND SO IT'S THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE REALLY STRUGGLING
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN LAID OFF
OR THEY'VE ONLY WORKED A FEW
HOURS- IF AT ALL. BET REALLY
REALLY DESPERATELY NEED HELP
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IT TAKES ALL OF THAT PUT TO
TOGETHER IN A PACKAGE AND AS
PART OF THE DISCUSSION. THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS COMMITTED
THAT THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT HAS BEEN. TARGETED IN OUR
BUDGET FOR LEGAL SERVICES WILL
GO OUT AND WE'LL GET PROGRAM TO
MEDIATE LEE SO THAT. THESE
OFFICES CAN CAN SERVE AS A
RESOURCE FOR- TENANTS THAT HAVE
BEEN SHOWING UP AT THEIR OFFICE
LOOKING FOR HELP AND
DESPERATELY NEED LEGAL ADVICE.
AND HELP IN BEING ABLE TO
MANAGE THIS THE SYSTEM IS IT
PERFECT NO NOTHING'S PERFECT
BUT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
EXTREMELY HARD- SENATOR
BRADFORD AND I STILL HAVE A
BILL. WHICH IS SB THREE WHICH
WE INTEND TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE AS AS ISSUES
ARRIVE AND I HEARD SOME GREAT
COMMENTS HERE. THAT MAKE A LOT
OF SENSE TO DO SOME WORK ON-
BUT I THINK IT THAT- THIS THIS-
SOLUTION BILL IS ELEGANTLY DONE
IT'S VERY FINELY CRAFTED AND
ARE THERE SOME THINGS ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO CHANGE YEAH
ABSOLUTELY WE'RE PROBABLY GOING
TO NEED TO GET OUT THERE AND
MAKE SOME CHANGES. BUT I THINK
IT ACCOMPLISHES EVERYTHING THAT
WE WANTED ONE IS TENANTS THAT
THE MORE TIME GETS EXTENDED
TENANTS GET TO STAY IN THEIR IN
THEIR- IN THEIR PLACES. SOME OF
THE BILLS GET PAID LANDLORDS
GET MONEY AND- AND MEANWHILE WE
CAN GET OURSELVES TO THIS
PANDEMIC AND SEE WHERE WE ARE
WE ARE IN JUNE BUT I. I INTEND
TO VOTE ON THIS BILL AND I AND
I THINK THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ASSEMBLY FOR WORKING SO HARD
WITH THE SENATE ON THIS. THANK
YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU. SENATOR
CABALLERO AND SENATOR DRAWS OF.
YEAH OKAY OKAY- YES I A. R. I
WANT TO THANK SENATORS
CABALLERO BRAD AND SENATOR
BRADFORD FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD
WORK I KNOW OFF AND ON I'VE
I'VE SPOKEN ESPECIALLY TO
CENTER CABALLERO- AND I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THE ALL THE HARD
WORK THAT EVERYBODY'S PUT INTO
IT I'M GOING TO SUPPORT AB
EIGHTY TO EXTEND THE
MORATORIUM- IT'S NOT PERFECT AS
EVERYBODY KNOWS BUT IT DOES THE
JOB OF PREVENTING THESE MASS
NUMBERS OF EVICTIONS THAT COULD
HIT CALIFORNIANS UNLESS WE TAKE
ACTION ALSO SUPPORT AB SEVENTY
NINE. TO IMPLEMENT THE FEDERAL
RENTAL ASSISTANCE FUNDS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO US- THEIR
NUMBER OF HOLES IN PROBLEMS I
DON'T BLAME ANYONE AT ALL- THIS
IS HIS HEART SO HARD ON A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT FRONTS- IT
IS OF CONCERN TO ME THAT IS A
CENTRAL ISSUE IS THAT LANDLORDS
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT BUILDABLE
RUNNERS ARE PROVIDED THERE ARE
RENTAL DEBT RELIEF- THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR AND THAT
THEY NEED OUR GOAL SHOUD BE
THAT NO RENTER WHO HAS BEEN
UNABLE TO PAY THE RENT BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC IS FORCED TO
LIVE WITH RENTAL DEBT HANGING
OVER THEIR HEADS FOR YEARS TO
COME. REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR
NOT A LANDLORD PARTICIPATES ARE
THERE OTHER ISSUES- THAT
SOMEONE'S UNSCRUPULOUS
LANDLORDS COULD ENGAGE IN
TRYING TO GET RID OF CERTAIN
KINDS OF TENANTS ARE RENTAL
HIGHER INCOME RENTER I URGE
LANDLORDS TO PARTICIPATE IN%
THIS UP AND THIS PROGRAM IT
WILL BE SO ESSENTIAL AND SO
IMPORTANT TO THE RUNNERS AND I
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUES. TO DO THESE FIXES
AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT THE BILL
AND HOW IT'S BEING IMPLEMENTED
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MEMBERS FOR THIS VERY
CONSTRUCTIVE DISCUSSION AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR WHO WORKED ON
IT AND NOW I WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON AB SEVENTY NINE I
MOVE EIGHT SEVEN EARLIER JUST
MOVED AB. SEVENTY NINE-
WATCHING THE FLOOR. QUICKLY H.
HAVE A REAL CALL THEN ON THE
MOST AB SEVENTEEN. AB SEVENTY
NINE MOTION IS TO PASS SKINNER
FIVE SKINNER HI NIELSEN AYE.
NIELSEN AYE BRADFORD. BRADFORD
HIGH CABALLERO. THE MAYOR
CORTESE RIGHT PARTISI I. DALI.
KELLY HI DORADO. ZERO ZERO FIVE
EGGMAN HI THANK YOU NINE
LAYERED ON LAYERED MCGUIRE
RIGHT HI MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE
MAN MAN I. NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN
AYE PHOTOBOOK AYE WHICHEVER AYE
PAN. STERN BY KELSEY HI CASKEY
I WILK HI WILK HI. CAN YOU GIVE
ME THE COUNTY CIRCUIT ANNOUNCES.
FIVE SIXTEEN ZERO RIGHT THE
BILL IS OUT OF WHICH SIXTEEN
ICE AND THAT WAS THE BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR WE WILL NOW TAKE A
MOTION ON AB AT MY MOVE- GREAT
SORRY AB AT- IS- DO YOU PASS.
AND- YOU CAN DO THE ROLL CALL.
AB AT MOTION IS TO PASS SKINNER
HI SKINNER HI NIELSEN. BRADFORD
PARK BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO
CAREER AYE CORTESE AYE CORTESE
AYE DOLLY. YOUR BROWSER ZERO
ZERO FIVE EGGMAN EGGMAN HIGH
LAYERED HI AYE MCGUIRE HI HI
MELENDEZ. MAN HI THIS THREE
MINUTES TO READ GIVE HIS NAME.
GENERATED BY A SETTLEMENT I
THINK YOU'VE BEEN HI. NEWMAN
AYE NEWMAN AYE CHOKO OKAY PAN.
TERM BY KELSEY KELSEY I OKAY. I
THINK THE VOTE WAS ELEVEN WHAT
CORRECT I GET THAT RIGHT. HIS
ELEVEN NO ZERO THANK YOU SO
THAT BILL WAS SIZE ELEVEN NO
ZERO IT'S ABOUT THE TV EIGHTY
THANK YOU ALL AND THANK
EVERYONE WHO I GAVE US PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY AND ALL OF A
CLEARLY AS I STATED EITHER IF
YOU DID WE'RE NOT ABLE TO OR
YOU WANTTO. SUBMIT TO US YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING PLEASE GO TO THE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND YOU CAN SUBMIT
THERE. ARE REALLY APPRECIATE IT
AND WITH THAT. THE COMMITTEE IS
A JERK.